PERSONAL STAFF TO THIS
COMMITTEE- ALSO THINK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE FOR
JOINING US- AS AS SOME OF YOU
KNOW- MY BACKGROUND IS AND I'M
ELECTRICAL ENGINEER BY
TRAINING- I'M ALSO AN EDUCATOR
AND FOUNDER OF A NON PROFIT-
THAT WORKS TO GET YOUNG GIRLS
INTERESTED IN STEM- SO I HAVE A
BACKGROUND IN THIS FIELD VERY
EXCITED. TO CONTINUE THIS WORK-
AS A STATE LEGISLATOR TO- YOU
KNOW AFTER BEING ELECTED- I
THOUGH THIS FIELD IS ONE OF MY
PRIORITIES TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON AND WHAT I QUICKLY LEARNED
IS THAT WE NEED TO GATHER
EVERYONE- THAT'S WORKING. IN
THIS FIELD ESPECIALLY COMPUTER
SCIENCE- TO LEARN FROM THEM TO
SEEWHAT WE CAN DO IN IN
CALIFORNIA TO- RECLAIM OUR ROLE
AS A NATIONAL LEADER IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE- AND SO THAT'S
WHY TODAY WHAT ARE THEME IS
DEBUGGING COMPUTER SCIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA. RECLAIMING OUR ROLE
AS A NATIONAL LEADER- IN STAFF
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
SILICON VALLEY WHICH IS WHAT
MADE- CALIFORNIA ON THE GLOBAL
LEADER IN STEM BUT STEM IS
EVERYWHERE IN OUR STATE IT'S
NOT JUST ONLY IN SILICON VALLEY
IT'S IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES- AND I THINK A LOT
OF YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THAT THEY CAN DO COMPUTER
SCIENCE. ANY IN ANY PART OF THE
STATE- AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK THAT- WE
FOCUS ON DEVELOPING A QUALIFIED
WORKFORCE AND GETTING YOUNG
PEOPLE INTERESTED- IN S
FIELD- 67% OF ALL NEW JOBS AND
STEM- ARE IN COMPUTING. I AND
ACCESS TO COMPUTER SCIENCE-
WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL FOR US IN
OUR STATE- TO READ CLAIM A
REGGAE JANE OUR LEADERSHIP. IN
THIS ROLE UNFORTUNATELY WERE
NOT ADEQUATELY PREPARING
CALIFORNIANS FOR OPPORTUNITIES
ON TO ENTER COMPUTER SCIENCE
I'M IN A RECENT STUDY BY THE
CAPER CENTER ONLY 3% OUT OF THE
ONE POINT NINE MILLION HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE ENROLLED IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND THEN WHAT IN
ADDITION WE KNOW THAT THAT 3%
IS NOT ETHNICALLY AND GENDER
DIVERSE- SO THEY ARE NOT
NECESSARILY REPRESENTATIVE OF
EVERYONE IN OUR STATE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME- YOU KNOW OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ARE
FALLING FURTHER BEHIND AND
MISSING OUT ON THESE
OPPORTUNITIES- IN STEM AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALL HERE VERY
DIVERSE- OF GROUP OF PANELISTS
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
FROM LABOR- EDUCATION TEACHER
THE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RESEARCHERS PRESIDENTS OF
UNIVERSITIES- INDUSTRY- WERE
ALL HERE TODAY TO SEE WHAT WHAT
HOW CALIFORNIA CAN REGAIN ITS
ROLE IN THIS FIELD. SO BEFORE
MOVING ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL- I
WON ACKNOWLEDGE COURSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND GIVE HIM
THE OPPORTUNITY GIVE A BRIEF
OPENING REMARK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S AN HONOR
FOR ME.
THIS IS AN AWESOME SO
THIS IS DIAGRAM BUDGET IS IN
OUR- FIRST OF DISCOVERED IS
THERE IS A ONE LET THEM IN MY
CENTER ACTUALLY ON ONCE IT'S ON
THE WHAT IS THE AND I DISCOVERY
SLATED. STILL. BUT THE IS
SOMETHING THAT I REALLY DEEPLY
PARTICULARLY IN THE CARE SAID
BASICALLY. A VIDEO GAME ON THE
ARE FIRED HUNDREDS OF SOFT
HERE'S A LOT FOR SO I KNOW
ABOUT WHAT JOB SKILLS ARE ANY
KIND OF THE CARD WITH THIS
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE STORES.
THE PROGRAM AND THE SKILLS THAT
YOU USE EFFORT A SUCCESSFUL A
JOB SO I'M INTERESTED
DISABILITY LAST AND ALL TO HAVE
A THE CHAIRS AND I REFER THE
WORKPLACE ESPECIALLY IF YOU
MINISTRY WE'VE GOT. DESPERATELY
MORE FEMALE SO. FOR HALF OF OUR
CUSTOMERS TO. IS OUR- AND SO WE
NEED PEOPLE CREATING THOSE
GAMES THAT REPRESENT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BUYING THEM BECAUSE
THEY CAN HELP US PUT THE
FEATURES IN THE GAMES THAT ARE
USEFUL TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE BUYING THEM SO- I'M
REALLY INTERESTED IN-
PARTICIPATING. THE PANEL AND
SING WHICH ALL HAVE TO SAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY OBERNOLTE I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BRIEF
WELCOMING REMARK. NO I DON'T
THINK- MY COLLEAGUES US NUMBER
RIVAS FOR. CONVENING ALL OF US-
AND REALLY BEING A LEADER ON
THIS CONVERSATION- EVER SINCE
YOU GOT ELECTED LEGISLATURE
I'VE BEEN HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH
YOU. AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
TO PARTNER WITH YOU- ON TRYING
TO- INCREASE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION AND ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS- THROUGH CALIFORNIA
AND- I KNOW THAT. THE AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING YOUR
OPENING REMARKS SO I HOPE I
DON'T REPEAT ANYTHING THAT WAS
COVERED BUT- I BET THEY WERE
AND- I'M GET WON'T DO THEM
JUSTICE BUT WANTED TO- JUST
KIND OF HIGHLIGHT. A COUPLE
THINGS AND ONE IS THAT WE NEED
DATA. AND THE STATE NEEDS GOOD
DATA. ON WHO HAS ACCESS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE- EDUCATION
CURRENTLY IN OUR MIDDLE SCHOOLS
AND HIGH SCHOOLS- AND DATA
BROKEN DOWN NOT JUST KIND OF
HIGH LEVEL DATA BUT KNOWING.
YOUR GENDER ETHNICITY- YOU KNOW
IT ARE THE STUDENTS WHO ARE.
ARE STEVEN FREE REDUCED LUNCH
ME ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT. REAL
GOOD QUANTIFIABLE DATA SO THAT
WE KNOW WHERE THERE ARE GAPS
AND WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT
ISN'T. A AND WHAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO DO BETTER TO TRY TO
INCREASE ACCESS- AND THEN
ANOTHER THING THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO FOCUS ON IS THE TEACHER
PIPELINE- AND MAKING SURE THAT.
TEACHERS ARE GETTING TRAINED-
THAT EARLY ON TO IT SO THAT
THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE TEACHING
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN OUR SCHOOLS
WHETHER IT'S INTEGRATING. C. S.
CONCEPTS IN THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL OR ACTUALLY TEACHING
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES- IN
HIGH SCHOOL- THAT'S SOMETHING
THATWE NEED A BILL THAT
PIPELINE AND HAVE IT BE A VERY
DIVERSE PIPELINE- SO THAT WE
SET THIS FOUNDATION UP
PROPERLY- SO THAT EVERY STUDENT
GETS ACCESS TO. THE HIGH
QUALITY COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION SO LOOKING FOR
WORKING ON THOSE ISSUES AND A
LOT OF OTHERS- IN THE COMING
YEARS. THANKS THANK YOU. SO
BEFORE WE OFFICIALLY START I
JUST WANNA MAKE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS. ON THE TABLE
NEXT TO THE ENTRANCE TO THIS
ROOM. HAS THE AGENDA- AND
BACKGROUND MATERIALS IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PICK THOSE UP-
AND IF YOU'RE WATCHING THIS
ONLINE- THE AGENDAS POSTED ON
OUR WEB PAGE AND ALL SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTS- WILL BE POSTED.
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS- AND
AS A REMINDER- TWO SPEAKERS-
YOU ALL HAVE FIVE MINUTES-
FOLLOWED BY. Q. AND A FROM THE
COMMITTEE- SO WE'LL START- WITH
THE FIRST PANEL- WE HAVE-
ALISON SCOTT. FROM THE CAPER
CENTER AND KARAN ROLLER- FROM
GIRLS WHO CODE. OUR FIRST
SPEAKER IS DOCTOR ALISON SCOTT.
WELCOME THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HOSTING THIS IMPORTANT MEETING
MY NAME IS ALISON COTTON AND
THE CHIEF RESEARCH OFFICER THE
KEEPER CENTER WERE LOCATED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA THE HEART OF
SILICON VALLEY- AND HAS THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN JUST MENTIONED-
WE KNOW THAT THE TECH SECTORS
PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN OUR STATE- HOWEVER THE MOST
MARGINALIZED GROUPS
SPECIFICALLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE FALLING FURTHER
BEHIND I'M AND WE SEE IT
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY INCREASING.
SO OUR MISSION AT THE KEEPER
CENTERS TO FOCUS ON- INCREASING
DIVERSITY INCLUSION ACROSS THE
TECH ECO SYSTEM SO I ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MY TEAM AND I DO
OUR CONDUCT CONDUCT RESEARCH
ON- ACCESS AND EQUITY IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION SO
TODAY I'D LIKE TO SHARE A FEW
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CURRENT
LANDSCAPE SOME OF THE DATA
POINTS THAT YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER- WHY IT MATTERS FOR
STATE AND THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
I THINK WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US
TODAY. SEC WELL. I HAVE JUST A
FEW SLIDES OF DATA HERE- SO WE
PUBLISHED A REPORT IN JUNE OF
TWENTY NINETEEN LOOKING UP FIVE
YEARS OF HIGH SCHOOL COMPUTER
SCIENCE. ACCESS ENROLLMENT IN
EQUITY DATA- AND THE FINDINGS
WERE CONCERNING TO US FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS- FIRST WE
FOUND THAT- JUST 39% OF ALL
HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
OFFERED. ANY COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSE AND THAT NUMBER IS MUCH
LOWER FOR THE ADVANCED
PLACEMENT COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES. ONLY ABOUT 14% OF ALL
HIGH SCHOOLS- AND WE SEE BY
THIS THE DARKER SHADES OF-
COUNTIES THAT COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES ARE. MOST LIKELY TO BE
CONCENTRATED IN THE BAY AREA IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
FOUND THAT RURAL SCHOOLS ARE
SEVEN TIMES LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES. IN TERMS OF ACCESS BY
SCHOOL DEMOGRAPHICS- WE FOUND
THAT LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS-
OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE OR
PARTICIPATING COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES JUST BECAUSE THE
COURSES ARE NOT OFFERED AFTER
SCHOOL THAT THE SAME RATES. SO
SCHOOL THAT ARE PREDOMINATELY
STUDENTS OF COLOR- ART TWO
TIMES LESS LIKELY TO OFFER- ANY
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE AND LOW
INCOME SCHOOLS ARE FOUR TIMES
LESS LIKELY TO OFFER ADVANCED
PLACEMENT COMPUTER SCIENCE A.
THIS THAT WAS JUST MENTIONED
EARLIER WHEN WE LOOK AT WHO
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATES IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE WE HAVE- OVER
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND ONLY 3% OF
THEM ARE TAKING ANY CS COURSE-
AND EVEN FEWER OF THEM ONLY ONE
PERCENT. ARE ENROLLED IN AP
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND I REALIZE
THAT THE GRAPH ON THE RIGHT IS
ACTUALLY PRETTY SMALL SO I'M
GONNA TALK ABOUT A FEW OF THE
DATA POINTS THERE- WHEN WE LOOK
AT CS ENROLLMENT BY RACE AND
GENDER. I'M JUST SIX THOUSAND
OF OUR ONE MILLION LET NEXT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE
TAKING- AP COMPUTER SCIENCE.
THE NUMBER THE LOWER FOR BLACK
STUDENTS WHERE JUST FIVE
HUNDRED OF OUR- HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND BLACK STUDENTS ARE
TAKING COMPUTER SCIENCE AP
COMPUTER SCIENCE. AND FEMALE
STUDENTS 27% ARE TAKING A PCS
A- JUST THIRTY NINE BLACK GIRLS
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE LIVE NEXT GIRLS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND- SO WHY
ARE THESE FINDINGS SO
CONCERNING TO US- A COUPLE
REASONS ONE THAT COMPUTATIONAL
THINKING AND KNOWLEDGE ARE
BASICALLY TO RECEIVE THAT WE
KNOW STUDETS WILL NEED ACROSS
ALL FIELDS OF STUDY. I'M TO
STUDENTS THAT ARE TAKING AP
COMPUTER SCIENCE ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO GO ON A MAJOR IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE- AND BE
PREPARED FOR- MAJORING IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE AT BUT A POST
SECONDARY LEVEL. I'M AND THEN
ALSO JUST AS A STATE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A DIVERSE AND ROBUST
COMPUTING WORK FORCE OUR
CURRENT TECH WORKFORCE IS
OBVIOUSLY NOT REFLECTIVE OF OUR
CURRENT STATE DEMOGRAPHICS-
AND- AS A- AGAIN OF THE STATE
WHAT WE WILL BE REDUCE THING-
INNOVATION AND EXACERBATING
INCOME AND WEALTH INEQUALITY OF
FOR NOT ADDRESSING THIS KEY
ISSUE. SO I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE
HAVE IS AN OPPORTUNITY IN FRONT
OF US DESPITE THIS DATA I
THINK. WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPROACH THESE DISPARITIES
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE- BY
PRIORITIZING POLICIES AND
STRATEGIES THAT REALLY
ADDRESSED THE- RACIAL GENDER
ECONOMIC AND GEOGRAPHIC GAPS
THAT WE JUST ON THE DATA- I
ALSO THINK WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THOUGHTFUL
AND STRATEGIC ABOUT ADDRESSING.
THAT ENTRANCED I COULD NOT- THE
EDGE ENTRANCED EDUCATIONAL
INEQUALITY ACROSS ALL SUBJECT
AREAS AT THE SAME TIME- SO WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE BY
SAYING I THINK WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE BOLD LEADERSHIP- BY
ANSWERING ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
PREPARED FOR. A PARTICIPATION
IN OUR FUTURE TACT OF AN
ECONOMY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AGAIN I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
K. THANK YOU DOCTOR SCOTT- OUR
NEXT SPEAKER IS OUR CURRENT
ROLLER- DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
FOR GIRLS WHO CO. I THINK I AM
FIRST THANKS A SIMILAR REQUEST
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY I'M
VERY EXCITED- TO TALK ABOUT
DAVID DAVIS SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEART
ACROSS THE CODE- SO GROSS A
CODE OR ANY YEAR OLD
ORGANIZATION- WE WERE FOUNDED
WITH THE MISSION TO CLOSE THE
GENDER GA. IN ENTRY LEVEL
TECHNOLOGY JOBS- WE DO THAT
FIRST AND FOREMOST THROUGH OUR
PROGRAMS WHERE WE NOTONLY
TEACH GIRLS TO CODE- BUT WE
GIVE THEM THE SKILLS TO
CONFRONT A LOT OF THE CULTURAL
STEREOTYPES BUT WHO AND WHAT.
OCCURRED LOOKS LIKE- A FEW
YEARS AGO YOU KNOW WE STARTED
TO SEE THAT THERE IS THIS
PROLIFERATION OF POLICIES
DESIGNED TO EXPAND. COMPUTER
SCIENCE IN SCHOOLS- WE REALIZE
THAT TO REALLY FULFILL OUR
MISSION OF REACHING GENDER
PARITY IN COMPUTER SCIENCE- WE
NEEDED TO START ADDRESSING THE
GENDER GAP IN IN. COMPUTER
SCIENCE CLASSES WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS. FIRST
THING WE DID WAS A WELL LET'S
LET'S LOOK AT THE DATA SURELY
IT EXISTS- BUT THE TO OUR
DISMAY WE REALIZE THAT THE ONLY
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA THAT
EXISTED WAS THROUGH THE COLLEGE
BOARD'S AP PROGRAM- THROUGH
PARTICIPATION. COMPUTER SCIENCE
EXAMS- YOU KNOW WE LOOKED AT
YOU KNOW IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE. ALISON CHIP MENTIONED
SORT OF A WHAT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE- BUT ALL OF ALL OF YOU
TWENTY. THOUSAND BPD PERCENT
EXAMS TAKE LASHER ONLY 30% OF
THE WERE GIRL. AND ONLY 8% OF
THE WERE ACROSS COLOR AGAIN I'M
JUST GONNA AFTER THIS- ONLY
FORTY NINE BLACK GIRLS AT THE
AP COMPUTER SCIENCE EXAM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR. AND THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE ALL OF THE
OTHER- COMPUTER SCIENCE IN
COMPUTATIONAL THINKING COURSES
THAT ARE BEING OFFERED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO THIS IS THE ONLY
PUBLIC DATA THAT EXISTS. ABOUT
WHAT THE GAPS ARE NOT JUST FOR
GENDER BUT FOR RACE FOR
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS. HOW
WE DON'T HAVE A COMPLETE
PICTURE OF. WHO'S TAKING
COMPUTER SCIENCE TO THOSE
CLASSROOMS LOOK LIKE THE
SCHOOLS THAT THERE AND- AND IN
POLICY BUT ESPECIALLY IN
EDUCATION POLICY WHAT GETS
MEASURED GETS MANAGED- IF
THERE'S NO DATA ON GIRLS. OTHER
UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE CLASSROOMS-
HOW ARE WE EVER TO KNOW IF
THOSE COMPUTER SCIENCE
CLASSROOMS LOOK LIKE THE SCHOOL
BRAND OR- THE COMMUNITIES
THURMOND- HOW. WE TO TRULY
EVALUATE THE POLICIES- THAT WE
ENACTED TO PUT COMPUTER SCIENCE
IN EVERY SCHOOL- AND HOW ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO KNOW IF ARE WE NOT
GETTING GIRLS IN THE FIRST
PLACE ARE WE LOSING THEM
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY HOW DO
WE REALLY MEASURE HOW WE'RE
DOING IT NOT JUST SORT OF THE
DIVERSITY ANGLE. BUT ALSO THE
INCLUSION ANGLE- BECAUSE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY- WE ARE SO
OFTEN TALKING ABOUT DIVERSITY
INCLUSION AND THEY OFTEN. YOU
KNOW COME ACROSS IN THE SAME
BREATH DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION-
BUT WE FORGET THAT THEY'RE VERY
DIFFERENT CONCEPTS- AND FOR
DIVERT DIVERSITY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE GETTING MUCH BETTER
AND COMPUTER SCIENCE- SO
THAT'S- YOU KNOW GETTING GIRLS
AND OTHER UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES- EXPOSED TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE SPARK THEIR INTEREST
I'M GET THEM INTO THE
CLASSROOMS AND CLUBS IN THE
FIRST PLACE- BUT INCLUSION IS
THE MUCH HARDER WORK- AND
THAT'S THE WORK OF CREATING
PERSISTENCE IN GIRLS TO PURSUE
COMPUTER SCIENCE. IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE AND AS A
CAREER. I'M BUT ALL OF THIS
REALLY START WITH DATA EIGHT.
I'M IF WE CAN IDENTIFY WHERE
THE GAPS ARE WITH A BIG. YOU
KNOW WE'RE THEY PURPOSE STAYING.
FOR WE DON'T KNOW OF GIRLS
SPEAKING. AT AT ALL WE CAN TIME
SEEING. TO CLOSE THOSE GUYS. AN
IT YOU KNOW YOU BE ASKING
YOURSELF WHY. WHY EQUITY YOU
KNOW WHY WE EVEN NEED TO BE
TRACKING PARTICIPATE WORDS
GOING PUT A COULD. SCIENCE AND
EVERY SCHOOL IN THE GIRLS WILL
COME- BUT IT YOU KNOW FOR US
ACROSS THE CODE WE REALLY THINK
ABOUT THIS SORT OF BEYOND JUST
A YOU KNOW THIS EQUITY LINES WE
THINK ABOUT THIS IN ECONOMIC
TERMS. AND WE THINK ABOUT THIS
AND INNOVATION TERMS- IT FOR
STARTERS WOMEN ARE THE PRIMARY
BREAD WINNERS AND 40% OF
AMERICAN FAMILIES- EVERYONE
TALKS A LOT ABOUT HOW. YOU KNOW
COMPUTER SCIENCE JOBS CODING
JOBS PAID YOU KNOW THREE TIMES
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE THERE SO
MANY MORE OF THESE JOBS- AND
FOR SO MANY FAMILIES AND FOR
GIRLS- THESE ARE JOBS THAT ARE
PATHWAYS INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS
FOR THEIR FAMILIES IN THE NEXT
GENERATION- SO THAT'S YOU KNOW
A REALLY PRIMARY CONCERN BEHIND
WHY WE NEED TO START TRACKING
THIS DATA AND MAKING SURE THAT
OUR CLASSROOMS LOOK LIKE OUR
COMMUNITIES- BUT I ALSO WANT US
TO. THINK MORE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
INNOVATIONS THAT RELIEVING ON
THE TABLE- BY NOT FOCUSING ON
THE GAPS- YOU KNOW FOR GENDER
FOR RACE FOR SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS ALL OF THOSE- WERE
REALLY LEAVING BEHIND. A
GENERATION OF CHANGED COURSE
WE'RE NOT GIVING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF INNOVATORS THE
SKILLS THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE
THE CHANGE IN THE WORLD. AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE LEAVING OUT AT A
TIME WHEN YOU KNOW WE NEED
INNOVATIONS AND TWIRLED MORE
THAN EVER. WE DON'T WANT TO
EXCLUDE ANY SEGMENT OF OUR
TO MAKE THOSE INNOVATIONS MAKE
THEM A REALITY. AND HELP YOU
KNOW CHANGE OUR WORLD FOR THE
FOR THE- SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CALIFORNIA QUESTIONS.
THANK KARAN I KNOW YOU YOU
TRAVEL FROM THE I THINK YOU'RE
ON THE SPEAKER THAT COME FROM
THE FOR THIS I THINK I'M PRETTY
SURE SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT FOR JOINING US HERE IN OUR
STATE CAPITOL ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE- SO NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. I HAD A QUESTION
FOR- MISS ROLLER- SO I DO WE
ARE IN COMPLETE AGREEMENT ON
THE NEED TO GET MORE WOMEN INTO
COMPUTER SCIENCE BUT- I FEAR
THAT WE ARE SHORT CHANGING THE
EFFORT IF WE FOCUS. IF OUR
FOCUS IN THAT EFFORT IS TO.
CREATE MORE COMPUTER SCIENCE
PROGRAMS AT HIGH SCHOOLS. WHICH
WAS WHAT- DOCTOR SCOTT WAS
TALKING ABOUT AND- THAN
MOTIVATE WOMEN TO GET INTO
THOSE PROGRAMS IT SEEMS OF TO
BE WHAT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND- IN MY EXPERIENCE
CULTIVATING. A PASSION FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND FOR
PROGRAMMING IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS BEST DONE AN ACADEMIC
SETTING. THE VERY BEST SOFTWARE
ENGINEERS THAT I HAVE KNOWN IN
MY CAREER OR THE ONES THAT. GOT
OUT OF BED WANTING TO CODE WENT
TO BED WANTING TO CODE YOU KNOW
HAD THAT THAT- PASSION DURING
PASSION FOR IT AND MOST OF THEM
STARTED OUT IN AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT IT WASN'T COMPULSORY AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH AN
ACADEMIC SETTING IS. YOU KNOW
YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE A CLASS EVERY
WEEK YOU HAVE AN ASSIGNMENT YOU
KNOW YOU ARE FORCED TO DO THIS
AND THAT'S NOT A CRITICISM OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE CURRICULUM
IT'S JUST A FEATURE OF.
ACADEMIA THE BEST IN THE TO
CULTIVATING A PASSION IS
HANDING SOMEONE A BOOK IN A
COMPUTER AND SAYING OKAY WHAT
HE YOU TEACH YOURSELF HOW TO
PROGRAM WORKS THESE DAYS BE AN
ONLINE PORTAL OR- KNOW
SOMETHING THAT SELF DIRECTED-
THERE WAS WITH WITH SOME
STRUCTURE TO IT BUT BUT
SOMETHING THAT THAT. REQUIRED I
THE- HE VOLUNTARY BY AND FROM
OTHER WOMEN THAT WERE TRYING TO
GET INTO THIS AND SO I'M
WONDERING IF THERE ISN'T LIKE
ANOTHER PRONG THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDED HERE TO MOTIVATE YOUNG
GIRLS YOU KNOW TO HAVE THAT
PASSION. YEAH I THINK I THINK
THAT'S RIGHT- I- YOU KNOW OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT FOR GIRLS-
THERE IF YOU SPARKLES
INTERESTING PETER SCIENCE.
BEFORE THE END OF MIDDLE SCHOOL
SHE'S MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
CONSIDER IT YOU KNOW TO TAKE IT
AS AN ACADEMIC SUBJECT IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND- IN A PURSUE IT AND
HIGHER AND AS A CAREER- AND SO
I AGREE WE NEED TO BE SPARKING
GIRLS EARLIER. IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
SORT OF LIKE THE LAST POSSIBLE
CHANCE WE HAVE- BUT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
OBVIOUSLY BETTER FOR THAT- I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW THE
SCHOOLS ARE THE PLACE WHERE-
STUDENTS. GET EXPOSED TO A LOT
OF DIFFERENT DISCIPLINES- AND I
THINK THAT EXPANDING COMPUTER
SCIENCE AT THE YOUNGER GRADES
IS REALLY VITAL- FOR SORT OF
SPARKING THAT INTEREST IN
SPARKING THAT- YOU KNOW JOY IN
CODING AND THEN YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY. ON TO
EXPLORE IT EXTRA CURRICULAR LEE
OR YOU KNOW IN SCHOOL- AT YOU
KNOW IN THE LATER GRADES AS IT
GETS MORE COMPLICATED AS THEY
NEED MORE- ADVANCED TRAINING IN
IT- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF SORT.
OF SCHOOL PROGRAMS- THAT
DIRECTLY TEACH GIRLS CODE. THE
GIRL SO BUT YOU KNOW MOST AT
THIS POINT ARE GETTING EXPOSED
TO COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
LEARNING TO CODE IN SCHOOL- AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS- YOU ADD THESE COMPUTER
SCIENCE COURSES ARE BEING
ADDED- THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET GIRLS.
INTO THEM AS WELL- SO THERE
THERE ARE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
RULES TO CODE OUT OF SCHOOL-
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT BEING
EXPOSED TO IT IN SCHOOL- WE
DON'T THINK THEY'RE GONNA
PURSUED THOSE OUT OF SCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES. YEAH I
UNDERSTAND LIKE I TILL CAN'T
HELP BUT THINKING THAT WITH
THEIR SOMETHING MISSING MAYBE
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT THAT
SPARKS THAT INITIAL INTEREST
LIKE. ON CODING COMPETITIONS OR
IN A REAL WORLD PROBLEMS THAT
ARE OPENED UP TO SOLUTIONS FROM
FROM- STUDENTS OR- INTERNSHIPS
WHERE WE PARTNER THEM WITH.
COMPANIES OR SOMETHING YOU KNOW
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE IT'S
NOT I HAVE TO. IT'S SOMETHING
WHERE. IS THERE MOTIVATED TO
TAKE THAT STEP THEM. YEAH AND
WE YOU KNOW WE SEE. GIRLS ALL
THE TIME ONCE THEY HAVE YOU
KNOW WANT TO HAVE EVEN THE MOST
BASIC TECHNOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE
WOULD SAY THOSE BASIC CODING
KNOWLEDGE. THEY WILL THEY WILL
THEY ARE SPARKED AND THEY GO
OFF ON THEIR OWN WE SEE GIRLS
COME OUT OF OUR PROGRAMS- THAT
HAVE YOU KNOW JUST A BASIC
CODING KNOWLEDGE- AND- THEY GO
ON AND THEY SAY OH I WANT TO
LEARN HOW TO DO THIS LANGUAGE
IN THIS LANGUAGE. AND THEN THEY
ARE BUILDING ALL KINDS OF TOOLS
BASED ON PROBLEMS THAT THEY'RE
SEEING- BASED ON SORT OF THIS
LIKE INITIAL SPARK- SO I. I
AGREE- AT BUT WE ARE AT IT WHAT
YOUR SAYING IS BORN OUT AND
WHAT WE SEE GIRLS BUILDING WITH
THEIR SORT OF- KNOWLEDGE OF
CODING AND COMPUTER SCIENCE.
THANK YOU CAN I JUST ADD ONE
OTHER COMMENT. I'M I ALSO GREEN
I THINK. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO THINK ABOUT THE ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN IN SCHOOL AND OUT OF
SCHOOL BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE KEPT SEEING TIME
AND TIME AGAIN OR STUDENTS WHO
GOT. SOME EXPOSURE IN AND OUT
OF SCHOOL LIKE COUPON OUR CAMP.
AND REALLY WANTED TO PURSUE
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND DIDN'T
HAVE ANOTHER PLACE TO GO IN THE
SCHOOL DAY TO CONTINUE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND SO I THINK. THE
MORE WE CAN ONLINE THOSE TWO
TOGETHER SO SPARKING INTEREST.
I'M GETTING STUDENTS I'M
INTERESTED IN ENGAGED AND THEN
HAVING A PLACE FOR THEM TO- TO
ENTER INTO A PATHWAY BEARD- I
AGREE BUT I MEAN I THINK THAT.
VOTE IN HIS. ON THAT. THERE
CAN. PASS THAT'S NOT A NOT A-
PATHWAY. AND MAYBE IT'S- YOU
KNOW. A COMPUTER PROGRAM AND-
THE OUT THEM YOU KNOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN FOR LACK
OF BREAKING OF THAT FEAR IS
AGREEMENT- NO I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM FROM MY
COLLEAGUE- OUT BUT IT REMINDED
ME OF A STORY THAT I'M GONNA
STEAL FROM RUN GONZALEZ WHO IS
THE FORMER MAYOR OF SAN JOSE-
WHO'S NOW THE CO I THINK STILL
OF THE HISPANIC FOUNDATION OF
SILICON VALLEY. WHO WOULD SAY
THAT WHEN HE BE TALKING WITH
WITH YOUNG STUDENTS IN EAST
SIDE SAN JOSE- AND HE WOULD ASK
THEM WHO KNOWS WHAT THE
ENGINEER IS- MOST THEM WOULD
RAISE THEIR HANDS- AND THEN THE
FEW THAT WOULD WOULD SAY
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO DRIVE THE
TRAIN- AND SO I THINK IT'S JUST
AWARENESS- AN OPPORTUNITY AND
ACCESS. THAT A LOT OF STUDENTS
DOESN'T COME IN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND FOR IN IN MY DISTRICT. FOR
THE KIDS WHO GREW UP IN PALO
ALTO THEY'RE BORN WITH AN IPAD
IN THEIR HANDS AND THEY'RE
DIGITAL NATIVES BUT TO- AND YOU
KNOW IT IT'S SOMETHING THAT. IS
SPARKED A LITTLE MORE
ORGANICALLY WITHIN THEM BECAUSE
THEY SEE IT EVERYWHERE AROUND
THEM- BUT I THINK THAT WE HAVE
A LOT OF COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THAT'S NOT THE
CASE AND WHERE. THE PARENTS AND
THE- ROLE MODELS IN THE
LEADERS. AND THOSE COMMUNITIES
DON'T WORK IN INTACT- AND SO
THE STUDENTS TO DON'T EVEN KNOW
IT EXISTS- AND SO IF YOU. DON'T
HAVE IT IN SCHOOL AND IF IT'S
NOT COMPULSORY IN SOME WAY
SHAPE OR FORM. IT DOESN'T. GET
THAT. OPPORTUNITY THAT IS THAT
THAT. MARK NEVER GETS. IGNITED
AND SO IT IT IS A FINE LINE I
THINK. YOU KNOW YOU'RE ACTUALLY
RIGHT THAT THE BEST WAY IS THAT
ORGANIC WAY. ON BUT A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY NEVER
EVEN GET THAT AGAIN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BEGIN WITH AND
SO HOW DO WE AND OF. EXPAND
THAT ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY-
THIS IS THE- IS A CHALLENGE NOT
THE- ONES WITH A- YEAH AND- TO
BUILD OFF OF THAT- BRUNCH TV
AT. STANFORD DID A STUDY ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO- ABOUT EXPOSURE
TO INVENTORS- AND A CHILD'S
LIKELIHOOD TO THEN BECOME AN
INVENTOR THEMSELVES- AND- IT.
IT VERY CLEARLY SHOWS THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE EXPOSED TO.
INVENTIONS AND INNOVATIONS AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AS CHILDREN
ARE. UNLIKELY TO GO ON- TO EVEN
YOU KNOW KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
THAT POSSIBILITY AS ADULTS- AND
SO YOU KNOW JUST THIS EXPOSURE
TO YOUNG AGE TO- THE NEXT
GENERATION OF TECHNOLOGY THAT.
GENERATION OF. HOLES CAN GO ON
TO SORT OF CREATE THE STATE.
CORRECTION OF MAKERS. OKAY
THANK YOU BEFORE WE MOVE ON I
WHEN IT KNOWLEDGE- THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
HAS JOINED US THANK YOU FOR
JOINING OUR COMMITTEE- AND I
HAVE A QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW.
A COMMENT TO YOU KNOW I. YOU
KNOW I WAS EXPOSED TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE WHEN I WAS TEN- THIS IS
IN THE EIGHTIES IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR- AS YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE COMPUTERS AT HOME OR
MOST OF A STUDENT- AND IT WAS
THROUGH SCHOOL AND IT WAS JUST
LIKE AN EXTRA CURRICULAR
ACTIVITY. IN MY FIFTH GRADE
CLASSROOM. I'M A I DIDN'T KNOW
AN ENGINEER YOU KNOW MY FAMILY
ARE IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO-
THEY'RE NOT PROFESSIONALS I'M
YOU KNOW JUST HARD WORKERS- BUT
I HAD. DIDN'T KNOW SCIENTISTS
DIDN'T KNOW AN ENGINEER I
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT THIS WAS
A CAREER I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST
A CLASSROOM ACTIVITY. JUST A
FUN ACTIVITY SCHOOL AND
REMEMBER THE MOMENT THAT MY
TEACHER TOLD ME. YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER THIS AS A CAREER.
WE'LL GET PAID TO THIS. I HAD
NO IDEA. THE CLASS I ASSOCIATED
WITH SCHOOL BUT IT WAS FN- AND
THAT'S WHAT CHANGED. MY LIFE
AND MY- MY FOCUS IN IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND THEN IN HIGH SCHOOL
WAS FOCUSING ON HOW CAN I DO
THIS. BECAUSE THAT I MEAN I
DON'T EVEN KNOW IS A CAREER
EVEN THOUGH I WAS DOING IT I
WAS PROGRAMMING. AND HAD NO
IDEA THAT IT WAS SOMETHING
PEOPLE DID FOR A LIVING- AND
ESPECIALLY BACK THEN WE DIDN'T
HAVE ALL OF THESE TECHNOLOGY.
YOU KNOW DEVICES AND IT WASN'T
AS PREVAIL AND OBVIOUSLY AS IT
IS TODAY. AND SO JUST SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THAT INITIAL EXPOSE
OUR- EXPOSURE I THINK CAN
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR A
LOT OF US THAT ARE FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. ARE
AND SO THANK YOU- FOR. ALL OF
YOUR QUESTIONS BUT BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL I HAD
A QUESTION. BOTH OF YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE LACK OF DATA- THAT WE
HAVE DO YOU HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW. WE CAN
COLLECT DATA SO WE CAN BETTER
IDENTIFY THE GAPS. I WELL. TO
START TRACKING IT IS WHERE WE
BEGIN I. AS A YEAR THERE AGAIN
THERE IS A VERY. YOU'RE A LACK
OF DATA ON COMPUTER BECAUSE
THERE'S A LACK OF IT ON
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES AND
PARTICIPATION- BROADLY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY- WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE AP EXAMS- AND SO TO
BEGIN JUST START TRACKING-
WHO'S TAKING A COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES- AND WHO'S TEACHING
THEM- WHERE THEY'RE BEING
OFFERED- WE YOU KNOW WE TRIED
IT WE WANT TO REALLY START
LOOKING AT WHERE THE GAPS ARE
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW GIRLS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS BY RACE I
SO SHE COULD NOT STOP LANGUAGE
LEARNER STATUS- BY DISABILITY
STATUS WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF WHO'S
TAKING THESE COURSES NUMBER
SEVEN JET JUST TO LOOK AT IT BY
IN THOSE CAPPERS JUST DECIDE
RIGHT SO WE TALKED A LOT THE IT
UP. FOR YOU BLACK GIRLS IN THE
AP COMPUTER SCIENCE EXAM HOW
MANY WHAT GIRLS ARE TAKING
OTHER COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES-
THAT ARE IN OUR SCHOOLS WOULD
YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW SO I
WOULD SAY. THE FIRST IS TO
BEGIN TO. IT AT THE SECOND
THING IS TO HAVE THAT DATA. BE
PUBLICLY REPORTED OUT- YOU
KNOW. WHAT GETS MEASURED GETS
MANAGE THERE'S SO MUCH DATA ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
SCHOOLS- AND IT'S ONLY THROUGH
YOU KNOW HAVING THE DATA BECOME
PUBLIC AND HAVING A
CONVERSATION. ABOUT WHERE THE
GAPS ARE AND WHO IS BEING
SERVED AND WHO IS NOT BEING
SERVED- THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
DESIGN POLICY INTERVENTIONS- TO
CHANGE THE DYNAMIC- SO I WOULD
SAY YOU KNOW START TRACKING IN
IN SCHOOLS AND START PUBLICLY
REPORTING THAT. IT OUT SO THAT
YOU KNOW THERE CAN BE A
CONVERSATION- AT ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE INTERACTIONS NEED TO
BE- AND WHERE- BECAUSE THERE'S
YOU KNOW WE- HAVE A HUGE.
BARGAIN BASEMENT- IN THIS NEW
DISCIPLINE IS REALLY EXCITING-
BUT WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE DOING THIS- WITH AN
EYE ON EQUITY- AND WITH AN EYE.
ON INCLUSION. DISTANCE AND I
JUST ADD TO THAT. SO ORDER FOR
US TO DO THIS I HAVE A STUDY
THAT WE PRESENTED THE DATA ON
WE HAD TO MERGE I THINK IT WAS.
THREE OR FOUR DIFFERENT DATA
SETS SO THE DATA IS BEING
COLLECTED AT CD AND- CD HAS
BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH AND
GIVING US THE DATA- BUT IT'S
NOT EASY TO ACCESS AND I THINK
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM IS
FIGURING OUT. LIKE TO DISAGREED
ALL OF STATE UP. BY DONE BY
GEOGRAPHY BY COUNTY. YOU HAVE
TO MERGE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DATA SETS SO THAT'S ONE IS TO
SIMPLIFY THE WAYS IN WHICH ON
THE DAY OF BEING. BOTH
COLLECTED REPORTED- IN SECOND-
FOR K. THROUGH. SIX WE HAVE
VERY LITTLE TO NO DATA ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THOSE
CLASSROOMS WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AS WE THINK ABOUT
EARLY EXPOSURE TO. COME UP THE
CAKES ABOUT ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION. YEAH AND SIR
ALAN DISCOTEK ONE MORE THING ON.
LOS CODE AND- THE PAPER CENTER
SHOULD NOW BE THE ONES TELLING
THIS. ABOUT WHAT HAPPENING
PETER SCIENCE IT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE TELLING ITS OWN
STORY. ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE- AND YOU
KNOW HI LIVING THE SUCCESSES
AND TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW.
THAT WHERE THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES WHERE YOUR SCIENCE
CLASSROOMS LOOK LIKE THE
SCHOOLS- AND LIKE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THERE AND SO-
WE- WE SHOULD NOT BE THE ONE
TELLING THE STORY AND SO THAT'S
WHY I WOULD SAY START WITH
TRACKING AND PUBLICLY REPORT
THE DATA AND HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF THE
VIDEO- THANK YOU WILL MAKE NOW
MOVE ON. TO OUR NEXT PANEL. OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE DEVELOPING A
QUALITY AND ACCESS SOFTWARE- SO
THIS PANEL WILL FOCUS ON HOW WE
CAN PREPARE CURRENT. AND
INCOMING WORK FORCE FOR THE
GROWING TECH INDUSTRY. WE WILL
ALSO EXPLORE HOW WE CAN BUILD
AN INCLUSIVE PIPELINE SO THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE. OUR FIRST TWO SPEAKERS
HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN THE
INDUSTRY IN TRAINING. THEIR
WORKERS FOR THE NEW WAVE. OF
TECHNOLOGICAL SKILLS NEEDED TO
STAY RELEVANT. OUR FIRST
SPEAKER WILL BE SAYS HAD THE US
SAYS THAT IS THE LEGISLATIVE
AND POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. AND THAT WILL HAVE
NICOLE RICE FOLLOW HIM I THINK
IT'S FOR YEAH. SO WE'LL START
WITH A SIDE AND THEN MOVED TO
NICOLE. A GOOD MORNING- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- SAYS ARE THE AS
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES CODERS OF CALIFORNIA.
KIDDING I GOT PROMOTED RIGHT
NOW WE ARE UNIONIZED VOTERS
EVERYONE. I SAW THE LOBBYIST
BEHIND ME THEY'RE FREAKING OUT.
THE IT IS- IT IS A PLEASURE- TO
BE HERE IS AN HONOR- A BACK
AGAIN WHERE- WITH MY- PARTNER-
NICOLE RICE IN THE C. CA- HI
WHEN I STARTED AT THE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL ONE OF THE
THINGS I WORK I WAS INVOLVED IN
WAS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND
ALSO THAT HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
PIPELINE TO THE TRADES. BACK
THEN- WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION OUR
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE AND WHAT HAD
HAPPENED TO THE ACTUAL SYSTEM
THAT ACTUALLY OF BEING-
ELIMINATED FROM HIGH SCHOOLS-
USED TO BE THE VOTE GETTING FOR
MANY REASONS THAT- WAS TAKEN
AWAY. AND SO WHICH WE SAW WAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
INDUSTRY- THE MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF
PRESIDENT AND THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES PRESIDENT GOT
TOGETHER AND WE SAW SORT OF THE
UNIQUENESS OF THE SOME AREAS
THAT WE HAVE WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES. HE WORKS IN
OF. THE OUR AT THE A OF TWENTY
SEVEN TO PRINT IS A WHERE WHEN
CAREER TECHNICAL AND- WAS
ACTUALLY. ALIVE AND WELL AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL SYSTEM THERE ARE
THOSE CANONS WERE EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN YEARS OLD- YOU SEEN
NEWS REPORTS ABOUT- HOW
APPRENTICESHIP IN CONSTRUCTION
BEING A GOOD WAGE JOB IN THE
UNIONIZED CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
ACTUALLY CAN BE EQUAL TO THE
SAME EARNINGS AS A COLLEGE
GRADUATE. KEEPING IN MIND A LOT
OF THE THAT THAT COLLEGE
GRADUATES AND KERR AND ALSO THE%
CYCLICAL NATURE OF CONSTRUCTION
THEY'RE STILL VERY MUCH
COMPARABLE. AND SO- WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR PROGRAMS AND HOW
MUCH MONEY WE INVEST INTO OUR
PROGRAMS- IT'S OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR STIR
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED IN EVERY
ASPECT OF THE STATE. WE BUILD
PRETTY MUCH ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THESE ARE NOT THE
JOBS OF THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
AND NINETEEN SIXTIES ARE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL WERE BUILDING COMPLEX
FACILITIES- WILL BUILDING THE
NEW RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS
OF TODAY. AND TOMORROW AS WELL
AS THE INDUSTRIAL OF FACILITIES
ARE STILL KEEP OUR ECONOMY
GOING AND SO WHY WERE WERE
INVESTED IN THIS PARTNERSHIP IS
BECAUSE WE WERE SEEING THAT THE
AGE HAPPENED TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
OLD. AND SOMEWHERE THERE WAS A
GAP. BETWEEN WHEN A PERSON
GRADUATED WORK DROPPED OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY DON'T
SEE THE RELEVANCE IN THEIR
EDUCATION OR OTHER FACTORS.
THAT WHEN WE SAW THAT IT THAT
PERSON WAS INTERESTED IN
ACTUALLY HAVING ACCESS TO A
GOOD QUALITY CAREER
CONSTRUCTION WE HAVE TO READ
MEDIATE A LOT OF ISSUES. SO WE
GOT INVOLVED IN THE SAID BACK
ON CAREER TACK WAS PRESENT THE
AGENT WAS EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
THESE ARE HIGH QUALITY JOBS.
AND SO. THE PARTNERSHIP AS
ACTUALLY PRODUCED A LOT OF
SUCCESS IT'S BEEN ALIVE AND
WELL FOR FIFTEEN YEARS IT'S
CALLED THE GET REAL COALITION-
IN EVERY SINGLE STATE WIDE
SCHOOL BOND WE HAVE
INCORPORATED MONEY. FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL FACILITIES- AND
EDUCATION AT ALL FIFTEEN
INDUSTRY SECTORS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
REPRESENTS RIGHT THERE SEVERAL
THEN WE PARTICIPATED IN SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDER REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES OBJECT CODE CARE OF
THE SCHOOLS OF THE FUTURE.
THERE'S MORE OUR THERE REPORT
THERE WAS FIFTH PAY ANY PAGE OF
CARE. AND THE NIGHT ONE DAY IS
ONE OF THE WAY WE DID. A THE
BOARD GO AWAY AND YOU KNOW THE
ONE AND IN A POST SO WE KEEP
THAT RIGHT WE AT IT AND HAVE A
CON. WITH LAW POLICY MAY AND
WORK WITH THE FARM OF IT. NOW
EVERY SINGLE BOND HAS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FACILITIES BUT HOW DO YOU HOW
THE FACILITY THAT ACTUALLY DOES
NOT HAVE ON GOING FINANCING
RIGHT. TO THAT THAT THE
FACILITY HAS ADEQUATE EQUIPMENT
STATE OF THE ART EQUIPMENT
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING SO
FAST AND IT'S INVOLVED IN ALL
ASPECTS OF CONSTRUCTION
MANUFACTURING AND SO ON AND SO
ON. SO WE'VE ALSO WERE VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN PASSING THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
CENTER CRACKED. TODAY'S PRETTY
MUCH CT DAY AT THE CAPITOL AND
WE'RE VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT
LATER ON THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL ACTUALLY BE
DISCUSSING THE STATUS OF
BACKGROUND. FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION PLUS DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
TO ACTUALLY HELP US SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAINTAIN THEIR C. T.
COURSES OPEN. THE WITH THE
TEACHER PIE. MAKING SURE THAT
TEACHERS ARE UP TO SPEED ON ALL
THE LATEST COURSES IN
TECHNOLOGY SO THAT THEY CAN
TEACH KIDS. ON THE PREVIOUS
PANEL TALKED ABOUT SIR THAT
SPARK AND THAT INNOVATION. AND
THAT'S RIGHT IN A LOT OF THESE
COURSES CAN ACTUALLY TRIGGER OF
THAT SPARK INNOVATION THE A LOT
OF THESE COURSES CAN ACTUALLY.
HELP STUDENTS MAINTAIN THEIR
INTERESTS AND EDUCATION.
THROUGH A DIFFERENT AVENUE THEY
COULD BE LEARNING ALGEBRA BY
WORKING LA AT ELECTRONICS
BOUTIQUE WORSE. THEY COULD BE
LEARNING GEOMETRY BY BUILDING A
SHED OR DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN IN THE
SCHOOL- WE PARTICIPATE WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- FACT I WAS IN
A SIZE MAKE- OF HEARING
YESTERDAY. AT THE CAPITOL
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES
ASSIGNMENTS SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS IN THE OBSTACLES
FOR HOSPITALS. AS I WAS DOING
MY RESEARCH I CAME UPON AN
ARTICLE OF THE- HOSPITAL IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON CATHEDRAL HILL.
STATE OF THE ART HOSPITAL-
TALKS ABOUT BILL BUILDING
INFORMATION MODELING WHICH ALL
OF OUR PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS
USE. OF ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE
MATERIALS. OUTSIDE FILTRATION
SYSTEMS FOR ACTUAL CLEAR AIR
THAT'S FILTERED INTO THE
HOSPITAL AND SO ON AND SO ON
AND SO ON HIGHLY TECHNICAL
HOSPITAL PART OF WAS. AT THE
PROJECT INVITED STE IT'S FROM
ON. HIGH SCHOOL WHICH IS A
CAREER RECORD CATION HIGH
SCHOOL SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
HASN'T ARE NOT EXPERTS IN
THERE. THEY INVITED HIM TO
VISIT LA THESE JOBS ACTUALLY
THAT. UP AT JOHN OF OUR FOR THE
ABSOLUTE OF. YOUR SITE AND THEN
DURING SELF. WHAT I WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST HERE IS THE STATUS LOW
TOWARD A MODEL TWO X. OUR
PARTNERSHIP TO OTHER AREA THAT
ARE NOT TRADITIONAL PERMISSIONS
SO TO HAVE A COMPRENDER SHIP
PROGRAM. FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I THINK YOU
SHOULD LOOK AT IT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS-
REORGANIZING THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM IS
COLLAPSING ALL OF THE WORK
FORCE PROGRAMS INTO ONE
DEPARTMENT CALLED THE-
DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBS AND A
HIGHER WAGES IT'S GONNA TAKE
AWHILE TO GET USED TO WRITE-
BUT IT'S INNOVATIVE KIND OF
IDEA BECAUSE THEY WERE LOOKING
AT A PARTNERSHIP. AND THE WAY
THAT IT'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
THE BEFORE THE BUILDING TRADES
AND ALSO EXPANDING THAT TO
NONTRADITIONAL INDUSTRIES SO I
WOULD LOOK AT THAT ALSO LOOK AT
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES THAT WE
ARE PARTNERED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHERE
WE ACTUALLY GIVE THEM THE
CURRICULUM THAT WILL ACTUALLY
HELP THE STUDENTS. WILL BE ITS
COLLEGE READY BUT ALSO CAREER
READY INTER INTER PRESSURE
PROGRAMS AND I THINK INDUSTRY
CAN BE VITAL AND ACTUALLY
PARTNERING WITH LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOLS AND SIX EC ESTABLISHING
THESE PARTNERSHIP ACCOUNT IS
OFFICIALLY WHERE THESE AREAS OF
TACK ARE VERY RICH RIGHT AND
SILICON VALLEY AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA WITH BIOTECH AS WELL
SO- LEAVE YOU WITH THAT AND
THINK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- AND FOR- YOUR
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE BUILDING
TRADES AND I HAD THE
APPRENTICESHIPS- SO WE'LL MOVE
ON- TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER NICOLE
RISE SENIOR POLICY DIRECTOR-
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER AND EVERYONE. ON
THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS SAID IN A RICE CALIFORNIA.
AND TECHNO SAYS HE- WE ARE THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND PLUS COMPANIES
ONE POINT THREE MILLION
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE PART OF OUR
MANUFACTURING FAMILY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE A GROSS
STATE PRODUCT OF ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. SO I RECENTLY SAW STAT
THAT SAD- IF THE INDUSTRY OF
MANUFACTURING WAS IT'S OWN
COUNTRY WE BE THE NINTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD SET OUT.
SO WE'RE WE'RE PROUD OF THAT- I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT NOT ONLY
IS IT A PLEASURE TO COME HERE
AND SPEAK BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
ON ON THIS ISSUE- IT'S ALSO OUR
HONOR AND PLEASURE TO BE A PART
OF THE PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE
GET REAL COALITION AND KOBE
CHAIRING NOT WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THE DANGER OF
US SHARING THE SAME MINDSET ON
THIS ISSUE IS THAT WE SHOULD
BUT WE ARE STILL EACH OTHER
TALKING POINTS SO. SAYS ARE HAS
NOT SAID A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT THAT I WILL ECHO- IN FULL
IN STRONG AGREEMENT AND RELATED
TO WHERE WE ARE WE'RE WE'RE
GOING ON THIS ISSUE. THERE'S
JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS THOUGH
I WANT TO ADD RELATED TO STEM-
BECAUSE I WHEN I WAS PRIVILEGED
TO GET THE INVITE TO COME HERE
AND SPEAK. I WENT BACK TO MY
MEMBERSHIP WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
CTP BUT WE DON'T TALK SO MUCH
ABOUT STEM IN THE MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY. AND SO I WANTED TO.
GO TO MY- MY INDUSTRY FOLKS AND
CHALLENGE THEM TO TELL ME YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN STEM AND MANUFACTURING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COMPUTER
SIZE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY. YOU KNOW HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT DELIVER THE
PROPER MESSAGE TO YOU ON THIS
BODY POLICYMAKERS. AND THE
FIRST THING BY GOD RESOUNDING
FROM EVERYONE IS. NICOLE STEMS
NOT JUST FOR IT IS NOT JUST FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE STEM IS LIKE
THIS CENTRAL BUILDING BLOCKS OF
BASICALLY ALL CAREERS INCLUDING
MANUFACTURING DEFINITELY ****
ARE SAID WITH THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. CULINARY ARTS WELL
BEING- AND THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON SO IT IS REALLY THAT
FOUNDATION IN THOSE FOUR
DISCIPLINES OF SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY. ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS THAT REALLY HELPS
THE STUDENT BUILD FROM THERE.
THE SECOND POINT THAT THEY
SHARED WITH ME IS THAT STEM IS
SYNONYMOUS WITH C. T. E. WORD.
ABOUT HOW DO WE BETTER DELAY
THIS DO WE- AND RETAIN INTEREST
IN IT HOW DO WE GET WOMEN HOW
DO WE GET POPULATIONS OF COLOR
INTERESTED IN IT. IT'S THE
INTEGRATION WITH CAREER TECH
EDUCATION BECAUSE CAREER TECH
EDUCATION BRINGS THAT DIED-
WORK BASED LEARNING AND THAT
RELEVANCY TO THE EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE AND STAMMER BRINGS
THOSE DISCIPLINES AS WELL AS
THE ACADEMIC. OF PHILOSOPHY IF
YOU WILL THAT'S ON TOP OF THAT
AND WHEN YOU COMBINE THOSE TWO
YOU GET A VERY POWERFUL ON
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE THAT CAN A
WEEK SOMETHING LIKE IT DID WITH
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. IN A
STUDENT AND HELP CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THEIR CAREER
ASPIRATIONS SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT IN THE
MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY REALLY
WANTS TO LEAVE YOU WITH IS THAT.
THINK ABOUT STEM A LOT MORE
BROADLY. THINK ABOUT STEM IS
NOT JUST AN ACADEMIC PURSUIT
BUT ALSO ONE THAT INCLUDES
CAREER TECH EDUCATION AND ALSO
THINK ABOUT STEM IS NOT
STARTING. AT FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY AND A POST SECONDARY
ENVIRONMENT THINK ABOUT STAND
BEING INTEGRATED FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE IT WAS JUST TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER- ABOUT THE- KIND
OF APTITUDE THAT STUDENTS ARE
COMING IN TO SCHOOL WITH. I
WOULD SAY THAT THERE ARE YOU
KNOW CHILDREN WHO HAVEN'T EVEN
STEPPED INTO A CLASSROOM YET
THERE ARE MORE PER SESSION IN
TECHNOLOGY THEN WE ARE. YET
STILL WHEN THEY GO INTO THAT
CLASS ROOM IT'S NOT INTERACTIVE
ANYMORE WE TAKE THE INTERACTIVE
DEVICE THAT THEY PLAYED WITH
WHY MOM WAS IN LINE AT THE
GROCERY STORE OR THEY WERE
WAITING IN LINE AT DISNEYLAND.
AND WE TAKE THAT AWAY FROM THEM
AND WE GIVE THEM A BOOK. THAT I
EVEN USE THIS YOU CAN'T TOUCH
THE PAPER AND GET THE
DEFINITION OR GET THE REAL LIFE
APPLE. SO WERE FOR ABOUT A
KATIE A EN BY ANY TWO. WE WERE
NEED TO THINK OF. HOW ALL DO
LIVE DURING THAT EDGY. ASK ME I
HAD THE SERGEANTS PASSAGE
INFORMATION AND THAT EXT ARE
INTO. AND WHAT WEEK. I IN THIS
SPACE AS FAR AS A CAREER PATH.
FOR STUDENTS AND IT TALKS OF
OUR WHITE PAPER WHY.
MANUFACTURING WE THINK THE
IMMENSE THEM STANDS FOR
MANUFACTURING AND WE KNOW THAT
IT DOESN'T STAND FOR JUST MAIL.
SOURCES ARE. AND WHY IT'S SO
NECESSARY IN OUR INDUSTRY TO
HAVE STEM BE A PART OF WHAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING THANK YOU
THANK YOU NICOLE SO WE HAVE TWO
MORE SPEAKERS AS PART OF THIS
PANEL SO MAYBE IF YOU COULD
EITHER SIT ON THE SIDE BECAUSE-
AFTER THEY- PRESENT. WILL DO
THE QUEUE IN A FOR THE FULL
PANEL- SO PLEASE DON'T GO
ANYWHERE SAYS THAT NICOLE. YES
YES WE ALL HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
YOU- BUT WE'RE GOING TO LET
THE- FINAL TWO SPEAKERS OF THIS
PANEL- PRESENT AND THEY WILL
OPEN IT UP TO Q. AND A FOR THE
FULL PANEL SO NEXT WE GET TO
HEAR FROM THE TECH INDUSTRY-
CAMERON DIMITRI IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE- CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SOUTHWEST FOR TECHNET.
THANK YOU CAN. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME AND- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND- AS I
SAID FROM THE BEGINNING I JUST
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING AND
WE'VE BEEN PARTNERING WITH A
NUMBER OF YOU AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A- REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO DRIVE FORWARD AND
SO THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
MEETING. MY NAME IS CAMERA
DIMITRI AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET. AYE TECHNO
IS THE NATIONAL BIPARTISAN
NETWORK OF INNOVATION ECONOMY
CIOS IN SENIOR EXECUTIVES. ARE
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP THINK OF IT
THIS WAY IS SOME OF THE MORE
ICONIC START UPS TO- THAT THE
BIGGEST COMPANIES THAT YOU'VE
HEARD OF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE COVER THE RANGE
OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
COMMERCE THE SHARING AND GIG
ECONOMIES- THE ADVANCED ECONOMY
TELEHEALTH CYBERSECURITY
VENTURE CAPITAL. FINANCE AND
FILL IN THE BLANK. I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN WITH FIRST THANKING
YOU FOR CONVENING THIS MEETING.
AND DISCUSSING THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
THE PRIVATIZATION OF STEM. IN
THIS MOST RECENT ANNOUNCED
STATE BUDGET. COMPUTING IS THE
FASTEST. GROWING AND HIGHEST
PAIN AND LARGEST SECTOR OF THE
JOBS IN THE UNITED STATES I IN
PARTICULAR IN CALIFORNIA IN
EVERY INDUSTRY AND IN EVERY
STATE. EVERY TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE A
CHANCE TO LEARN ABOUT
ALGORITHMS AND HOW TO MAKE APPS
OR HOW THE INTERNET WORKS. SOON
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THESE THINGS FOR
POTENTIAL CAREERS BUT EVEN IF
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN COMPUTER SCIENCE THEY
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE USERS OF
TECHNOLOGY. EVERY PERSON WILL
INTERACT WITH SOME TYPE OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE WERE TACK IN
THEIR DAILY LIVES WHETHER WHEN
YOU GO INTO THE CAR WHEN USING
YOUR OWN CELL PHONE AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS MENTIONED
BEFORE IS STUDENTS AND
INDIVIDUALS KNOW HOW TO USE
THEIR TAX. I WITH MORE THAN.
FOUR THOUSAND OPEN COMMUTING
COMPUTING JOBS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LESS THAN HALF
OF ITS PUBLIC SCHOOLS. ACTUALLY
OFFERING THIS FUNDAMENTAL
SUBJECT. THERE'S A CLEAR GAP
THAT EXISTS IN OUR CURRENT STEM
PIPELINE. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY UNABLE TO MEET THE
GROWING DEMAND FOR SKILLED
ENDEAVORS TECH WORK FORCE. AND
THIS THREATENS OUR ECONOMIC
GROWTH COMPETITIVENESS
INNOVATION INEQUITY. EDITION AS
YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE DR
AT DOCTOR SCOTT- THAT
STATISTICS REGARDING THE GAPS
IN GIRLS AND UNDERREPRESENTED
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE CS
PIPELINE IN CALIFORNIA IS
DEEPLY TROUBLING. AND COMPOUNDS
IS ALREADY SHORTAGE AND
EXISTING CS WORKERS. TECHNO
MEMBER COMPANIES UNDERSTAND
THIS IMPORTANCE AND WE'VE BEEN
PROACTIVELY ENGAGED- FROM-
PHILANTHROPIC STANDPOINT
COMPANIES LIKE DEMOCRAT
COMPANIES LIKE MICROSOFT
DEMONSTRATE THEIR COMMITMENT TO
EXPAND IN EQUITY AND ACCESS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE THROUGH
PROGRAMS LIKE THIEL'S TEO'S
WHICH STANDS FOR TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION AND LITERACY AND
SCHOOLS. CONNECTS CLASSROOM
TEACHERS WITH TECH INDUSTRY
VOLUNTEERS TO CREATE
SUSTAINABLE CS PROGRAMS AND
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW DO YOU
CAN TO KICKSTART THIS
CONVERSATION OUTSIDE OF THAT
THE NORMATIVE CLASSROOM SETTING.
I'LL MICROSOFT ALSO AS PROGRAMS
LIKE DID YOU GIRLS WHICH IS
AIMED AT MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
GIRLS THIS FOCUS PRIMARY
PRIMARILY ON PROVIDING STUDENTS
WITH BETTER IDEAS OF WHAT A
CAREER IN TECH COULD LOOK LIKE
FOR WOMEN. I AND THEN PROVIDING
WITH MENTORS AND- REAL LIFE
EXAMPLES OF WOMEN THAT ARE IN
THESE POSITIONS OF POWER SO THE
GIRLS CAN EMULATE THESE
INDIVIDUALS. OTHER COMPANIES
SUCH AS MICROALGAE APPLE HAVE
EMPHASIZED CODING AS A CREATIVE
ACTIVITY THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE
EVERYONE CAN CREATE. WHICH
TEACHES STUDENTS. TO DEVELOP
AND COMMUNICATE IDEAS. THROUGH
VIDEO PHOTOGRAPHY MUSIC AND DRY
ANSWER THINKING I'M A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAT CREATIVE CAPACITY
BECAUSE EVERY TIME PEOPLE THINK
OF CS THEY THINK OF YOU KNOW
HARD SCIENCE BUT- AS WE KNOW
THAT YOU CAN EMBED A LOT OF
CREATIVE COMPONENTS WITHIN.
COMPUTER SCIENCE. APPLE IS ALSO
COMMITTED TO EXCESS ABILITY
ACROSS THE BOARD TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND IS MADE MANY
EFFORTS. TO MAKE CODEINE
EDUCATION AVAILABLE TO BLIND
AND DEAF STUDENTS. THROUGH
THEIR EVERYONE CAN CODE
INITIATIVE. TRANSACTION PRIVATE
INDUSTRY IS ONLY ONE COMPONENT
OF THIS- OUR INVESTMENTS IN OUR
VOLUNTEERISM OR NOT THE FIX ALL
SOLUTION AS WE THINK THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE. BROADER SYSTEMIC
POLICY SOLUTIONS AND SEARCH FOR
THIS READ TECHNO IT'S BEEN VERY
PROACTIVE AND COLLABORATING
WITH THIS YES FOR CA COALITION.
IN AS MANY OF YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT GROUP
ALREADY. THE GOAL OF THIS
PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION IS THAT
EVERY STUDENT DESERVES A CS
EDUCATION THAT WILL GIVE THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED.
REGARDLESS OF THERE'S A CODE
THE RACE GENDER AND THEIR
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND. I WOULD
NEED A MULTI FACETED APPROACH
THAT CONTINUES TO BUILD OFF OF
THAT WELL IT DOWN A LOT DURING
THE STATE'S BOARD OF. THE DOT.
FOR CAN SCIENCE TWENTY XIN PLAN.
THIS IS YES DEVELOPMENT O THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE. I JUST WILL
HELP SOME THAT. KIND OF THE
CRUX OF THE ISSUES THAT WE THE
C. PIPER ISSUE. REGARDING
PREPPING TEACHERS COUNSELORS
AND ADMINISTRATORS WITH MORE CS
PROFESSIONAL PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROVIDING INTEGRATION OF CS. IN
OTHER FIELDS IN STUDIES AT THE
PRE SERVICE LEVEL- INTEGRATING
COLLEGE AND CAREER PATHWAYS
THAT THEY DID NOT SO SIDE LOAD
BETWEEN C. T. AND- TRADITIONAL
NORMATIVE EDUCATION. AND
ADDRESS IN CS- CREDENTIALING
ISSUES WHETHER THROUGH
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATIONS OR
EVEN. THROUGH THE CREATION OF
AN EVENTUAL CS SINGLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS YOU KNOW WE'RE RUNNING
SHORT ON TIME IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO SUM UP. AND SO WE
CAN MOVE ON TO I JUST SPEAKER
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST.
TECHNO WE BELIEVE CS EDUCATION
IS A CRITICAL FOUNDATION AND WE
WANT TO DO WHAT WE CAN IN OUR
POWER TO BE ABLE TO EMPOWER
THAT AND THROUGH IT. THROUGH
THE CREATION OF EDUCATION
POLICY THAT AMERICA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CAMERA ARE NOW
SPEAKER IS JULIE FLAP IN CO
DIRECTOR FOR CS FOR CALIFORNIA
AND DIRECTOR OF THE UCLA. CS
EQUITY PROJECT THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMORY OF US FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND HOSTING THIS
STEM COMMITTING HEARING ALSO
I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN OBERNOLTE. AND
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR BEING HERE
AND BEING OPEN TO HEARING ALL
OF THE WONDERFUL INFORMATION
THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
SHARED. I'M MY NAME'S JULIE
FLAP AND I SAID AT THE
INTERSECTION OF POLICY RESEARCH
AND PRACTICE. THE LEADER OF
THIS AND ARE ACCESS- UCLA
COMPUTER SCIENCE EQUITY
PROJECT. AND I ALSO COOLEY THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE FOR
CALIFORNIA. COALITION SO. I
REALLY WANTED TO START WITH-
WHY ARE WE HERE WHY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT COMPUTER SCIENCE
WIDE IS COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION MATTER. AND EVEN
THOUGH I'VE LISTED THESE AS ONE
TWO THREE THERE CERTAINLY NOT
MEANT IN ORDER OF IMPORTANCE
BUT REALLY- THERE SO INTEGRATED
AND ONE IS SOMETHING THAT WE-
HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT IS THE
ECONOMIC IMPERATIVE OF MEETING.
THIS INCREASED DEMAND FOR
SKILLED WORK FORCE. AND THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO SPUR INNOVATION
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
OPPORTUNITY GAPS WHEN WE LOOK
AT INNOVATION OUTCOMES IS WHO
HOLDS PATENTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THEIR HUGE DISPARITIES AND
SO- HOW DO WE FOSTER A SPIRIT
OF INNOVATION AND CREATIVITY.
SO THAT- WE HAVE MORE- CREATIVE
PRODUCTS. AND THEN THE ON THE
THIRD IS THE HIGH INCOME
POTENTIAL WE KNOW THAT THESE
ARE THE FASTEST GROWING AND
HIGHEST PAID JOBS. THE
IMPERATIVE HAS TO DO WITH A G.
AND AGAIN IT'S REALLY RELATED
BUT COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
HOLDS THE PROMISE. TO PREPARE
STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE CAREERS
AND ALSO SOMETHING THAT GETS
SHORT SHRIFT IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS IS COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT HOW DO WE ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE. IN OUR DEMOCRACY
USING TECHNOLOGY AND HOW DO WE
THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT HOW THAT
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE USED FOR
GOOD- A COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION ALSO HELPS IMPROVE.
OUR COMPUTATIONAL THINKING
CRITICAL THINKING AND
COLLABORATION WHICH ARE REALLY
THE FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SKILLS FOR THE WORK
FORCE. AND K. TWELVE ACCESS TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION IS
ALSO LINKED TO CS COLLEGE
MAJORS WHICH HOLDS MORE
PROMISES STUDENTS FURTHER
REFINE THEIR INTEREST IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE. AND THE
EQUITY IMPERATIVE. REALLY
CONNECTS BOTH THE ECONOMIC IN
THE EDUCATION IMPERATIVE AND
THAT IS THAT WE NEED TO BE MORE
MINDFUL ABOUT HOW WE INCREASE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR- THERE'S RESEARCH FROM
THE MACKENZIE- COMPANY THAT A
DIVERSE WORKFORCE. ACTUALLY
PRODUCES BETTER SOLUTIONS- WE
ALSO NEED TO HAVE MORE VOICES
AT THE TABLE IN OUR DEMOCRACY
AND ALSO- IN THE PLANNING ROOM
AS WE DEVELOP MORE CREATIVE
PRODUCTS. AND HOW DO WE DEVOTE
USE TECHNOLOGY TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS IN OUR COMMUNITIES SO
HOW CAN THIS INCREASED ACCESS
INTERRUPT THE- THE INEQUITIES
THAT WE SEE IN OUR SOCIETY. SO
OFTEN TIMES WE THINK ABOUT
CAREERS AND TECHNOLOGY AND- NOT
WE THINK ABOUT CAREERS IN THE
TECH INDUSTRY AND I THINK WE
WANT TO BE REALLY CAREFUL THAT
WE HIGHLIGHT THAT THESE CAREERS
ARE MUCH BROADER THAN JUST IN
THE TECH INDUSTRY. BUT COMPUTER
SCIENCE KNOWLEDGE IS
INCREASINGLY NEEDED WHETHER
STUDENTS PURSUE WITH THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT FINANCE HEALTH
CARE AGRICULTURE AS MY
COLLEAGUES NOTED ALL OF THE-
INTERSECTIONS IN THE TRADES AS
WELL. SO COMPUTER SCIENCE IS
ACTUALLY A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
LITERACY WE'RE NOT PURSUING
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION IN
THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE THINK
EVERY STUDENT SHOULD BECOME A
COMPUTER SCIENTIST JUST LIKE WE
DON'T. HAVE EVERYONE STUDY
BIOLOGY BECAUSE EVERYONE SHOULD
BECOME A BIOLOGIST BUT THESE
ARE FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS THAT WE
SHOULD ALL HAVE SOME EXPOSURE
TO. AND SO THESE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SKILLS CAN EASILY BE
FOUND IN HIGH QUALITY COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION CLASSROOMS.
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT
THIS- THE COMPUTER SCIENCE FOR
CALIFORNIA COALITION IS MADE UP
OF EDUCATORS INDUSTRY
ADVOCATES- NONPROFITS POLICY
ADVOCATES MANY OF WHOM ARE HERE
TODAY AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE. FOR BEING HERE- WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE TAKE
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT WE NEED TO HELP DRIVE OUR
ECONOMY TO HELP INCREASE EQUITY
IN EDUCATION. AND HOW TO CREATE
THAT PIPELINE IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO JUST SAY YES WERE ON BOARD
WITH COMPUTER SCIENCE BUT WE
NEED TO DIG A LITTLE BIT DEEPER
AND SAY WHAT IS SOME OF THE
UGLY STUFF BEHIND THE SCENES
THAT WE HAVE TO UNPACK. IN
ORDER TO PRIORITIZE EQUITY AND
CREATE A SOLID FOUNDATIONAL
STRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
HIGH QUALITY COMPUTER SCIENCE
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. AND
THAT MEANS COMPUTER SCIENCE
THAT PREPARES KIDS FOR COLLEGE
CAREERS AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS- AS CAMERON
NOTEDWE'RE WORKING ON ISSUES
AROUND TEACHER CREDENTIALING
HOW DO WE PREPARE TEACHERS TO
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE STUDENTS AND
CURRICULUM. HOW DO THEY
LEVERAGE- THAT PHONE THE
CURRENCY THAT STUDENTS ARE
USING IN THEIR EVERYDAY
COMMUNICATION AND SAY OKAY
LET'S NOT PLAY ON THE PHONE HOW
DO WE PROGRAM THE PHONE HOW DO
WE USE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
STUDENTS ARE ENGAGED IN EVERY
DAY. AND SOLVE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE MEANINGFUL TO THEM IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE'RE
WORKING ON BUILDING THIS THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT COMPUTER
SCIENCES EQUITABLE SCALABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT IN DOING THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR A
PARTICIPATING- NOW I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN- THE- BACK UP TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OF
ALL THE FOUR SPEAKERS- THAT
WERE ON THIS PANEL. IF ANYONE.
OKAY I'LL START WITH AS A
MEMBER P. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND THANK YOU ALL OF YOU FOR
JOINING US FOR THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION- IT WAS
GREAT TO HEAR ALL THE
PERSPECTIVES. AND ALSO I THINK
IT WAS GREAT TO HEAR THAT FOLKS
THAT ARE PRETTINESS FROM
DIFFERENT ANGLES HAVE THE SAME
PERSPECTIVE IN A SHARED
PERSPECTIVE. THE AS WE ALL KNOW
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING SO MUCH
OF WHAT WE DO AND HOW WE DO IT-
IT MANY OF THE JOBS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING IN TEN YEARS
DON'T EVEN. EXIST TODAY AND
AUTOMATION IS COMING FAST
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS
COMING FAST AND OUR TECHNOLOGY
DRIVEN WORLD HOLDS BOTH A TON
OF PROMISE AND ALSO A TON OF
CHALLENGES AND- YEAH I THINK.
WHEN WE'RE FACED WITH THAT
PIECE OF CHANGE AND THAT SCOPE
OF CHANGE THE RESPONSE CAN
OFTEN BE FEAR. RIGHT THERE CAN
BE A DESIRE TO RESIST THAT
CHANGE TO TRY TO STOP IT TO
LEGISLATE AGAINST IT TO. KNOW
LEGISLATE AGAINST JOB LOSSES
AND- I THINK WHEN WE SEE THAT
FEAR RESPONSE WHEN WE'RE ACTING
FOR A PLACE OF FEAR. WE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES SAYS MY QUESTION
FOR EVERYONE IS. HOW CAN WE-
BECAUSE HOW CAN WE HELP MOVE
FROM AS A REACTION OF FEAR AND
HELP PEOPLE. APPROACH THIS
CHALLENGE THESE OPPORTUNITIES
WITH A VIEW THAT SAYS. LET'S
ENSURE THAT WE'RE PLANNING FOR
THIS FUTURE LET'S ENSURE THAT
WERE BEING THOUGHTFUL AS WERE
PLANNING. AND LET'S ENSURE THAT
WE ARE CREATING AS MUCH
OPPORTUNITY AS POSSIBLE FOR ALL
THE EXTRA RISE AS SAD. AS AS
OUR JOB ELEGIES CHANGE. LEFT
HERE FOR ME OKAY. THAT A THAT'S
A QUESTION I THINK SOMETHING
THAT- FOR ME I LOOK BACK AT AT
HISTORY THE HISTORY OF THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND- HOW
APPRENTICESHIP ACTUALLY WAS
CREATED AND WHAT- CONTINUES TO
BE. SURE THE EXISTENCE OF
UNIONS THAT WERE ORGANIZED IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY. AND THROUGH
DIFFERENT CHANGES IN
TECHNOLOGY- THROUGH THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION THROUGH.
THE SORT OF YOU KNOW THE
GREATEST SORT OF MANUFACTURING
THE CALIFORNIA- WITH ALL THE
AEROSPACE AND- YOU KNOW JUST SO
MUCH HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT THAT CHANGED AND SO MANY
JOBS- HAD TO BE SORT OF ADAPTED
SO MANY CRAFTS. LOOKED AT THE
TRAINING ANTICIPATED TO
PREPARED THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY- WE HAVE THIS SO
EVOLUTION THAT TAKES PLACE- IT
HAS TO BE AN EVOLUTION IN OUR
CLASSROOMS BROSSEAU IN OUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BECAUSE
WE ARE BUILDING THE STATE OF
THE ART FACILITIES. WE HAVE A
JOURNEY PERSONS THAT COME BACK
AND HAVE TO RE SKILL AND
RETRAIN. I THINK SO THAT IS
HAPPENING- I THINK THERE'S SORT
OF A GLOBAL SUGAR FEAR OF THE
ACCELERATION OF HOW MUCH
TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING FASTER
THAN IT EVER HAS BEFORE- WHAT
WE VIEW IS THAT TECHNOLOGY
SHOULD BE ASSISTING PEOPLE
TODAY. AND ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
BETTER JOB AND HAVE A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE DOING THEIR JOB
AS WELL MAING IT SAFER NOT
NECESSARILY REPLACE. AND SO IF
THERE IS GOING TO BE- A AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR. YOU KNOW SOME
KIND OF AUTOMATION THEN I LOOK
AT IT WILL CAN WE THEN BUILD
THE AUTOMATION MACHINES CAN WE
THEN OPERATE THEM CAN WE-
PROVIDE MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES HERE TO KINDA.
OFFSET WHAT COULD BE A
REPLACEMENT OF SOME WORK SO
THAT THERE IS NO LEAKAGE-
PARTICULAR BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
INVEST SO MUCH INTO THIS I
THINK THAT. THERE'S A- GOOD
SORT OF WAY TO LOOK AT
EDUCATION AND HOW IT TIES TO
BUSINESS HOW TO CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR BUSINESS TO STAY
IN CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO HOW TO
REWARD THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE RIGHT THING
BY HIRING WORKERS PAYING
WORKERS ARE RIGHT WAGES. AND
IMPROVING THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
AS WELL SO I KNOW IT'S AN
ONGOING THING IT'S TIED TO
OTHER ISSUES AS WELL. TIED TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH
POLICIES THERE BUT- THIS IS
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ONE
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ON. SELECT
PSYCHIC. THERE'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER TO UP SKILLED WORKERS
AND TO CREATE NEW AND BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
ALL ACROSS THE STATE I THINK.
NUYS MR DIMITRI YOU POINTED
OUT. WERE ALREADY KIND OF
FEELING THE BITE FOR. A JOB
FIRST IT'S NOT PREPARED FOR THE
NEEDS OF THE MARKET WE ARE
SEEING JOB GROWTH SLOW. NOT
BECAUSE WERE FIRING PEOPLE NOT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT AVAILABLE
JOBS THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE. ARE
NOT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
SKILLED WORKERS TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS SO. THAT TO ME WHILE
THERE'S A TON OF RISK FOR IT IN
TERMS OF OUR ECONOMIC OUTLOOK.
THAT TO ME SAYS THERE'S A TON
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO.
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
IN BETTER JOBS AND ALSO TO
CONTINUE TO GROW THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND ENSURE WHERE. A
GLOBAL LEADER. ASSEMBLYMEMBER I
HAD A QUESTION FOR CISAR I
THOUGHT YOUR COMMENTS ON
APPRENTICESHIP WERE 1100% SPOT
ON. I THINK WE NEED MORE
FRIENDSHIPS AND MORE
INTERNSHIPS BECAUSE WE CAN USE
THOSE TOOLS TO TAKE A LARGE
POOLS OF PEOPLE AND IDENTIFY
THE ONES THAT US. A CAREER IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE IS APPROPRIATE
FOR AND GIVE THEM THEIR
OPPORTUNITY WHERE AS YOU KNOW
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY IN OTHER SETTINGS
BUT THERE'S SOME UNIQUE LEGAL
CHALLENGES. IN CODING THAT MAKE
APPRENTICESHIPS INTERNSHIPS
MORE DIFFICULT I WANTED I WANT
TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
BECAUSE- I MEAN WE ADVICE DID
YOU USED TO HAVE INTERNSHIPS.
AND WE HAD TO STOP DOING THEM
BECAUSE- WHEN YOU'RE CREATING
SOFTWARE- THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CODING ARE CREATING
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND YOU
NEED A CLEAR CHAIN OF OWNERSHIP
FOR THAT INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE CREATING A
SOFTWARE FOR A CUSTOMER. YOU
HAVE TO WARRANT TO THEM THAT
YOU HAVE COMPLETE OWNERSHIP OF
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE
DEVELOPING FOR THEM AND IF
YOU'RE CREATING A FOR AN END
USER- IF YOU CAN'T YOU COULD
OPEN UP YOU KNOW THIS THIS
PRODUCT THAT YOU INVESTED TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DEVELOPING- TO BEING PULLED OFF
THE MARKET IF ONE- CLAIM OF. OF
INFRINGEMENT WE WERE TO COME UP
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
HAVE THIS CHAIN OF OWNERSHIP SO
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE THAT DO
CODING. YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S A WORK MADE FOR
HIRE AND IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU
THAT YOU'RE PAYING THEM AND
EXCHANGE FOR A FAIR WAGE
THEY'RE GIVING YOU THERE THE
PRODUCT OF THEIR WORK AND I
MEAN THE PROBLEM WITH
INTERNSHIP OR THEY'RE NOT
GETTING PAID OR PARTNERSHIP FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE IS PAYING ON
THEM. THIS YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
CLEAR CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP SO I
WONDERED IF YOU HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS ON ON. YOU KNOW MAYBE
SOME CHANGES WE CAN MATER TOOLS
THAT WE CAN USE TO OVERCOME
THOSE DIFFICULTIES AND EXPAND
THOSE PROGRAMS. I THINK YOU
STOP ME ON THAT ONE I MEAN.
THAT'S A- HI I HAVE. YOUR
COMMON I I'D I'D I DO THINK. A
PARTNERSHIP CAN BE USE A
NONTRADITIONAL INDUSTRIES I
THINK THERE'S A- CLEAR PATH
TOWARD PREPARATION TO. OPEN IT
UP FOR DIVERSITY AND JUST. YOU
BRING PEOPLE WHEN THEY DON'T
HAVE THE- ACCESS TO A LOT OF
THESE RESOURCES BUT- BUT WHAT
YOU'RE MENTIONING THERE- I'M
NOT SURE BUT IT IS NOT REALLY
SOMETHING THAT IS IN
CONSTRUCTION. RIGHT IN
CONSTRUCTION WE HAVE. HERE'S
THE BASIC ENTRY WAY WHAT WE
WILL BE DONE WITH UP FOR
EXAMPLE IS PRE APPRENTICESHIP.
WE DEVELOPED A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP CURRICULUM AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL ALL THE-
INTERNATIONAL UNIONS GOT
TOGETHER AND SAID THIS IS WHAT
WOULD. PREPARE A STUDENT. TO
ACTUALLY KNOW ABOUT
CONSTRUCTION GET THE REMEDIAL
HELP THEM GET THEIR GED IF
THEY'RE NOT HAVING THEIR
DIPLOMA. GET THEM PREPARED WITH
A BASIC LEVEL MASS IN THE SOFT
SKILLS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO.
HAVE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY APPLY FOR. AND GET AN
APPRENTICESHIP. AND THAT'S
CALLED THE MULTI CROP CORE
CURRICULUM. AND SO A STUDENT
GOES TO THIS PROGRAM. AND THEY
LEARN ALL THE ASPECTS OF ALL
THE TRAITS. RIGHT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM. SO THAT WHEN THEY-
ACTUALLY GET THE CERTIFICATE
AFTER SIX MONTHS OR PROGRAM.
AND THE I EVEN DO EXERCISE AND
PHYSICAL SORT OF ACTIVITIES TO
GET THEMSELVES KIND OF. MINE
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY PHYSICAL
JOB AS WELL. AND SO WHEN THEY
GRADUATE FROM THIS PROGRAM. THE
THAN CAN LOOK AT WHERE THE NEED
IS. SO IF THERE'S US OVER
SATURATION OF THE LABORERS OR
THERE'S OVERSATURATION OF IRON
WORKERS AND THEY'RE NOT
ACCEPTING. THEY CAN LOOK AT
ELECTRICIAN'S PROGRAMS SHEET
METAL PROGRAMS PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS. GLAZERS PRIDE
PAINTERS WHATEVER THEY THEY CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE AN INTEREST AND-
AND THEY STILL HAVE THAT SHOT.
IF THERE IS A WAY. TO SORT OF
HAVE A BASE. TYPE OF ACCESS.
WORDS NOT PROPRIETARY THIS
NURSE NO SORT OF LICENSING
ISSUES OR- YOU KNOW.
INFRINGEMENT ON SOME COPYRIGHT
I DON'T KNOW MAYBE THEY COULD
BE SOME BASE WHERE A LOT OF
COMPANIES CAN GET TOGETHER. AND
SAY WE CAN PROVIDE THIS AS AN
APPRENTICESHIP WERE
PREPARATION. AND THEN ONCE YOU
GET THEM INTO YOUR ACTUAL
COMPANY. THE. AND YOU CAN
BECOME A FULL FLEDGED. THAT YOU
CAN. SHARE WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
IT WOULD NOT BE. OUR MODEL.
IT'S MULTI EMPLOYER. AND WE GO
WE FINISH THE JOB AND WE GO TO
THE NEXT CONTRACTOR AND SO ON
IN THE NEXT PROJECT. BUT IT
COULD BE VERY WELL THAT THEY
GET HIRED AS AN APPRENTIC AND
THEN THEY STAY WITH THAT
COMPANY AS A AS A SINGLE
EMPLOYER WHILE I UNDERSTAND.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT ONE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY I MEAN TO BE
FINE FOR A FURNACE TO WORK FOR
MULTIPLE EMPLOYERS. IT'S JUST
THAT YOU NEED TO BE ABSOLUTELY
SURE FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT
THAT WHEN YOU PRESS RIGHTS THE
LINE OF CODE. THAT ACTUALLY
MAKES IT INTO A FINISHED
PRODUCT. THAT THE CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP IS THERE TO BE ABLE
TO WARRANT TO THE CUSTOMER.
THAT THEY OWN THE PRODUCT THAT
WAS CREATED SO IT SOUNDS LIKE
MAYBE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS NEED
TO SIT DOWN. AND MAYBE HASH
THIS OUT TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
IF THERE'S SOMETHING A LEGAL A
SAFE HAVEN THE NEEDS TO BE
CREATED OR- OR SOMETHING
BECAUSE- I THINK WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT THE-
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
INTERNSHIPS ARE GOOD THING. BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
CARE BE BACK ON THAT I THINK
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THESE TYPES
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WE- LOOK AT.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND ON
THE JOB TRAINING AS BEING
SYNONYMOUS AND- A BRIDGE A
PROGRAM IS JUST ONE. OPTION OF
AN ON THE JOB TRAINING PROGRAM
SO. PERHAPS THE WAY TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF THESE UNIQUE MRS
THAT MAKE OTHER INDUSTRIES
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT.
CONSTRUCTION TRADES HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BILL SUCCESSFULLY. IS
TO LOOK AT OTHER ON THE JOB
TRAINING MODELS. THAT MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT FOR DIFFERENT FROM
EACH OTHER IN DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES. BUT BE ABLE TO
CREATE SOMETHING. THAT CREATES
THE SAME BENEFITS AS AN
APPRENTICESHIP MODEL BUT ISN'T.
TRYING TO STICK THAT ROUND PEG
INTO THAT SQUARE HOLE. TO BE
ABLE TO MEET SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES. YEAH AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN MY STUDIO WE
DON'T HAVE INTERNSHIPS ANYMORE-
WE HAVE. A PROVISIONL
EMPLOYEES. RIGHT AND SO WE ARE
YOU KNOW BUT BUT WE HAVE FEWER
OF THEM THAN WE USED TO HAVE OF
INTERNS. SO IT'S HARDER TO GET
THAT. LEG UP YOU KNOW THAT
FIRST STEP. WHICH IS WHICH IS A
SHAME BECAUSE- YOU KNOW YOU
REALLY YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PERSON. YOU KNOW. MAYBE FROM A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY MAYBE
FROM AN UNDERREPRESENTED.
ETHNICITY THAT YOU KNOW JUST
NEEDS THAT SHOT. YEP ANYWAY
THANK YOU. SO THE SOUNDS LIKE A
GREAT. ISSUE WHICH IS OUR GOAL-
OF THIS SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU. ON
THIS I MEAN I THINK ESPECIALLY
THE APPRENTICESHIP MODEL WHILE.
IT WILL BE EXACTLY THE SAME AS
IT IS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES I THINK THERE'S A LOT
THAT WE CAN LEARN- FROM YOU'VE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL. STATE WIDE AND
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES OF YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE. YOU KNOW
REPRESENTATION FROM. OF LOTS OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
WE TALK ABOUT COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND THE NEED FOR THAT-
INCREASING- ACCESS AND EQUITY.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
THIS MODEL AND I THINK
EVERYONE. IN THIS ROOM. ARE
THESE ARE THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
NEED TO DISCUSS IT SO. I THINK
WE CAN- IN THE FUTURE MOVE
FORWARD- JUST FOCUSED ON THAT
AND HOW THAT CAN BE A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL- YOU KNOW ONE
THING I THINK ABOUT. THE WITH
WITH MR DIMITRI THE OTHER
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THAT ARE THE CLOSEST TO THESE
TECH HUBS THAT SEEM TO GET A
LOT OF THE RESOURCE SAYS FROM
OUR- CORPORATE CORPORATIONS-
BUT- YOU KNOW IN PETERS SCIENCE
LIKE. REALLY MENTIONED IS EVERY
IN A LT OF DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES- SO WHAT CAN WE DO-
TO YOU KNOW REACH- COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT CLOSE TO THESE TACK
HOBBS- OR IS THE INDUSTRY
WORKING ON THAT. YEAH AND BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER IT SO. YES I
MEAN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE VERY ENGAGED AND I THINK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THINKING
ABOUT COMMUNITIES LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH MAY BE
DON'T NECESSARILY GET THE KIND
OF ATTENTION THAT- YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE SILICON
VALLEY AND WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
NEARBY AREAS DOES GET. SO I
THINK ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN REALLY PROACTIVE
WITH IN THE CS FOR CA
COLLECTIONS BECAUSE WE SEE ONE
WAY IS TO ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
BUILD OUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN THE PRE EXISTING SCHOOLS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES TO GIVE
THEM THE TEACHERS THE SKILL
SETS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
ACTUALLY. BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT HI REGULAR OF COURSE WORK
THAT IS NEEDED IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE WHICH IS SOMETHING THE
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE. WE'RE
NOT SEEN AND SO THOS CLASS THE
SCHOOLS AND LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AREN'T GETTING. THE
KIND OF EDUCATION THAT THEY
NEED IN THE STUDENTS ARE ARE.
KIND OF. THREE THERE AT THE GAP
AND OF THAT AND SO WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS BE ABLE TO HELP
MITIGATE THAT DO PROVIDING
BETTER TEACHER PREPARATION- AND
MORE COURSEWORK AVAILABLE IN
THOSE AREAS AND THEN FROM WHAT
I'VE SEEN AND DOUBTS THAT OUR
COMPANIES ARE VERY ENGAGE
WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
NOT JUST IN THE SO CALLED
pBUT IF THERE'S WAYS THAT YOU
KNOW THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PARTNER IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
MORE AND MORE AND BUILD IN
THOSE- FOOT PRINTS NO WE'D BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT. AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M SO I
WANT TO. MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL.
PANEL AND THANK. ALL OF YOU ON
THIS PANEL FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS- SO WE WILL SEE
OUR FIRST SPEAKER- WILL BE-
MARIA CLUB MAY FROM. DOCTOR
MARIA CLOUT CLOUT OF A-
PRESIDENT OF HARVEY MUDD
COLLEGE- IN FOLLOWED BY ALEXIS
KERRIGAN FROM CO .ORG SO HAVE
THEM SET UP. UP HERE TO BE
READY TO PRESENT. ASSEMBLY. SO.
LET'S SEE I THINK YOU COULD SIT
IN THE MIDDLE. YEAH SO WILL
START- WITH DOCTOR MARIA CALL
THEY PRESIDENT HARVEY MUDD
COLLEGE- SHE'S A LEGEND IN THIS
FIELD- AS SOME OF YOU KNOW I
HAVE FOLLOWED HER FOR YEARS-
AND HER WORK AND INCREASING
DIVERSITY AT HARVEY MUDD
COLLEGE IN COMPUTER SCIENCE- I
RECENTLY VISITED. HARVEY MUDD
COLLEGE AND MET HER AND ASKED
HER MONTHS AGO TO BE ON THIS
PANEL SO I WANT TO THANK HER
FOR JOINING US TODAY SO HANDED
OVER TO HER. SO FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME I'M THRILLED TO BE
HERE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE DONE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
IN CALIFORNIA DONE IT
NATIONALLY BUT IT'S JUST. IT'S
A GREAT PLEASURE TO BE HERE SO
I HAVE A FEW TAKE AWAYS THE I
WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH AND I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY LOT OF-
INSTITUTIONS. TO ORGANIZATIONS
TO GET MORE ACCESS TO COMPUTER%
SCIENCE IN CASE WHO TWELVE. BUT
FOR MY PURSE. OR AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND I SPENT A LOT
OF TIME DOING THAT AS WELL
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER. THE POINT
I WANT TO MAKE IS. IT'S NOT TOO
LATE TO START IT FIRST YEAR
UNIVERSITY. AND IN PARTICULAR
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO
ENDED UP MAJORING UP OVER THE
TIME I'VE BEEN OF MUD IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE WERE FEMALE OR
A PERSON OF COLOR DID NOT HAVE
ANY COMPUTER SCIENCE BEFORE
THEY GOT THERE. AND IN FACT- I
WAS VERY LUCKY SO. WHEN I
ARRIVED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE DEPARTMENT AT
MUD HAD STARTED HAD NOTICED
THEY HAD A BRAND NEW SYSTEM
PROFESSOR WHO JUST FINISHED HER
PHD AT MIT. CHRISTINE OF RADO
AND SHE HAD NOTICED THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN MAJOR IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE AT MUD WAS
ABYSMAL IT WAS ABOUT BETWEEN
1015% WHICH MEANT IT WAS EITHER
TWO OR THREE STUDENTS PER YEAR.
AND THERE WERE OTHER PLACES-
THAT HAD BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
ATTRACTING MORE WOMEN TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE- THE FIRST TO
DO SO WE'RE CARNEGIE MELLON.
AND THE U. S. AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF BRITISH COLUMBIA
AND CANADA WHICH IS WHERE I WAS
AT THE TIME AND I STARTED THAT.
IN SO THE DEPARTMENT DECIDED
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO THINK
ABOUT HOW THEY COULD CHANGE
THINGS SO THAT THEY COULD RAISE
THE NUMBER OF WOMEN MAJOR IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE MUD. NO WITHIN
FOUR YEARS WE WERE UP 240% WHAT
DID THEY CHANGE THE FIRST THING
THE CHANGE WAS HOW THE TOP
CAUGHT THE INTRODUCTORY COURSE
SO J. THE INTRODUCTORY COURSE
I'M ASSEMBLYMAN OBERNOLTE SORRY
J. THE WAY THEY TAUGHT THE
INTRODUCTORY COURSE. BEFORE SO
EVERYONE WAS REQUIRED TO TAKE
IT AND IT IN THE FIRST
SEMESTER. SO AS YOU WERE SAYING
AND IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
DESPISED COURSES EXCEPT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
PROGRAMMING SINCE THEY WERE SIX
OR TWELVE OR WHATEVER WHO ARE
MOSTLY GEEKY GUYS I JUST WANNA
MAKE IT REALLY. VERY CLEAR I
WOULDN'T MAKE IT VERY CLEAR.
I'M A GEEKY PERSON MYSELF I'M
MARRIED TO A GEEKY GUY AND MY
SON IS A GEEKY GUY LIKE ONE
TIME. WHEN I JUST MY FIRST
VISIT TO MUD AFTER IS ANNOUNCED
WE PRESIDENT MY DAUGHTER CAME
WITH ME AND EFFORT SHE SAID YOU
KNOW THIS IS A REALLY NICE VERY
DORKY BUT NICE NICE. DORKY SHE
SAID MONTH YOUR DORK YOU'RE
MARRIED TO A DORK AND YOUR
OLDEST CHILD IS A DORK HOW
WOULD YOU KNOW. SO ANY HELP
JUST TO MAKE THAT CLEAR SO THE
CHANGE THE INTERCOURSE. AND
WITHIN THE VERY FIRST SEMESTER
THAT IT WAS TAUGHT. IT BECAME
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR COURSES
WITH IN MUD AND WITHIN FIVE
YEARS IT BECAME PROBABLY THE
MOST POPULAR COURSE AT THE
COMMON COLLEGES. SO I JUST
WANNA TELL YOU I GOT THE
STATISTICS YESTERDAY. SO RIGHT
NOW- WE GRADUATE ABOUT SEVENTY
COMPUTER SCIENCE MAJORS PER
YEAR. UP ROUGHLY HALF ARE
FEMALE THOSE ARE MUD STUDENTS
WE ALSO GRADUATE PROBABLY FORTY
TO FIFTY. YOUR SCIENCE MAJORS
WHO ARE FROM THE OTHER
CLAREMONT COLLEGES SOME TO GIVE
YOU SOME STATISTICS OVER
JUNIORS AND SENIORS MAJORING
COMPUTER SCIENCE TODAY 45% OR
FEMALE. FROM THE STUDENTS WERE
MAJOR IN COMPUTER SCIENCE WITH
OTHER COLLEGES 51% FEMALE. IF I
LOOK AT RACE BECAUSE RACE IS AT
LEAST AS IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
UNDER REPRESENTATION MAYBE MORE
SO THAN GENDER FROM THE
STUDENTS WERE MAJORING IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE IT'S FOUR
POINT 2% AFRICAN AMERICAN
SEVENTEEN POINT 7% HISPANIC.
THE ZERO POINT 3% NATIVE.
HAWAIIAN OR OTHER PACIFIC
ISLANDER. STE TWELVE POINT 5%
TWO OR MORE RACES. THE QUITE IS
26% ASIAN IS 22% SO IF YOU PUT
TOGETHER BLACK AND HISPANIC
IT'S MORE THAN THE NUMBER OF
ASIANS ARE ALMOST THE SAME AS
THE NUMBER OF WHITE STUDENTS
AND IF I ADD IN THE OFF CAMPUS
MAJORS THE ONES WHO ARE AT THE
OTHER CLAREMONT COLLEGES. IT'S
ROUGHLY THE SAME NOT QUITE AS
STRONG. SO THE FIRST THING I
WANT TO SAY IS YOU CAN TEACH
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN A WAY. THAT
IS HIGHLY ATTRACTIVE MOTIVATING.
TO PEOPLE WHO'VE NEVER WHO
HATED COMPUTERS UNTIL THEY GOT
TO COLLEGE OKAY THIS. BECAUSE
NOT EVERY UNIVERSITY TEACHERS
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN A WAY IN
THAT INCLUSIVE WAY. THE SECOND
THING I WANT TO SAY WHICH I
THINK WAS TALKED ABOUT IN THE
LAST PANEL IS THAT IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO GIVE
WOMEN AND OTHER
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
REALLY MOTIVATES THEM THAT'S A
SPARK WHICH IS REALLY WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING. AND SO WHAT WE DO
IT MIND IS WE EITHER PROVIDE IN
THE SUMMER AFTER THEIR FIRST
YEAR WE TRY TO GET THEM EITHER
INTO RESEARCH EXPERIENCE ON
WORKING SO ON SOME SOCIETALLY
RELEVANT THING USING COMPUTER
SCIENCE OR WE HAVE WORKED WITH
ALL OF THE TOP TECH COMPANIES
TO START EARLY INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM SO GOOGLE MICROSOFT
FACEBOOK. AMAZON APPLE THEY ALL
HAVE EARLY INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS
NOW WHERE THEY WILL TAKE
STUDENTS AS EARLY AS AFTER THE
FIRST YEAR. AND GIVE THEM THAT
EXPERIENCE. AND SO WHAT WE KNOW
IS FROM RESEARCH IS THAT IF YOU
CAN GET. WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR INTO AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE WHITE WHAT THEY'VE LEARNED
CAN BE USED TO SOLVE IMPORTANT
PROBLEMS. THEY STAY IN THE
GRADUATE. AND THEN THE FINAL
THING IS THE MAIN OUR MAJOR
CHALLENGES FINDING ENOUGH
COMPUTER SCIENCE INSTRUCTORS
AND TRAINING THEM TO TEACH
INCLUSIVELY. SO I'LL JUST
MENTION WE'RE STARTING A NEW
PROGRAM THAT MUCH THIS YEAR
CALLED THE POSTAL CAN INTRODUCE
PLEA COMPUTATION. WHICH IS TO
HELP BRING PEOPLE FROM OTHER
DISCIPLINES WHO DONE IT PHD
THAT USES COMPUTATIONAL
APPROACHES LEARN HOW TO TEACH
COMPUTER SCIENCE A DATA SCIENCE
INCLUSIVELY. WE'VE ALSO WORKED
WITH SEVERAL OTHER INSTITUTIONS
TO HELP THEM ATTRACT MORE WOMEN
AND- FULL OF COLOR TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND I JUST WANTED VERY
QUICKLY CLOSE BY SAYING- IF YOU
DON'T KNOW ALREADY ABOUT WHAT
SUCH HERE NO RYAN AND HAS DONE
AT CS U. CSU MONTEREY BAY AND
HEART NO COLLEGE YOU REALLY
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT IT AND WE
HAVE SOME MATERIALS FOR YOU
ABOUT THEIR PROGRAM. THEY'VE
WORKED WITH THE COHORT OF
STUDENTS FROM SALINAS SO
VIRTUALLY ALL STUDENTS OF
COLOR- SOMETHING LIKE 37%
FEMALE- PARENTS HAVE NEVER GONE
TO COLLEGE AND- HAD A
GRADUATION OF SOMETHING CRAZY
LIKE ALMOST 80% AFTER FOUR
YEARS WHICH IS UNHEARD OF FOR
CSU AND- COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO.
THE ONLY MESSAGE I WANT TO
LEAVE WITH YOU. IT'S POSSIBLE
IT'S NOT EVEN THAT HARD TO DO.
BUT IT DOES REQUIRE SOME
RESOURCES SO I'M NOT ASKING FOR
RESOURCES FOR HARVEY MUDD BUT
THE CSU SYSTEM AND THE- NEW
CALL SYSTEM REALLY NEED
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE DEMAND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SHE REMINDED ME OF MY
INTRODUCTORY CS COURSE AT MIT
AND HOW IT WASN'T INCLUSIVE AND
HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS IT IT WAS
CONSIDERED A WEED OUT COURSE-
FOR US- AND- SOME OF US MADE
IT- BUT I NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THAT YOU KNOW I DON'T. I THINK
WE SHOULD MOVE TOWARDS MAKING
ALL INTRODUCTORY COMPUTER
SCIENCE COURSES INCLUDE
INCLUSIVE SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT THOSE POINTS SO
NEXT WE HAVE. ALEXIS HARRIGAN
I'M DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR CO DOT
ORG WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR WOMAN AND I AM SO HONORED
TO BE ON A PANEL DR- CHLOE WHO
IS SUCH AN ESTEEMED LEADER- OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE I IN THE COME
IN THIS COMMUNITY NATIONALLY I
ADD TEXT. OUR TEAM OUR TEAM UP
FLUID IN OUR RICHARD SEATTLE AT
THE NO SITTING ON THIS PANEL-
WITH HER AND SO WE MIGHT HAVE A
STAND UP TUNING IN FROM SEATTLE
JUST TO HEAR YOU. AND I
ACTUALLY ALSO DID TEACH I DID
TAKE AN INTRODUCTORY TO
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE AND I
WAS ONE OF THE STUDENTS WHO WAS
WE DID OUT IT WAS TERRIBLE IT
WAS NOT INCLUSIVE IT WAS NOT-
THERE WASN'T CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE- CURRICULUM AND- WE
CREATED A VIDEO GAME IN A FOR A
AND KICK THE BALL IT WAS. BUT
IT WAS NOT GREAT AWESOME SO
PROUD TO WORK FOR CO .ORG A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT FOCUSED ON
EXPANDING ACCESS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION. TO
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS WE
DEFINED AS FEMALE STUDENTS-
BLACK LATINA AND NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS MY NAME'S
ALEXIS MIRACLE HERE AGAIN AND I
AS I MENTIONED THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME. I'M GOING
TO SKIP OVER SOME OF THE
TALKING POINTS I NORMALLY GET
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
SPOKEN ON THE PREVIOUS PANELS
HAVE SHARE THAT INFORMATION-
THE ONE PIECE THAT I DID NOT
HEAR AT THE MENTION THOUGH IS.
THAT THE SALARIES AND THE
OPPORTUNITY I WITH THE OPEN
JOBS THAT EXIST SO IN
CALIFORNIA- THE AVERAGE
COMPUTING OCCUPATION HAS AN
AVERAGE SALARY OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND. DOLLARS A
YEAR WHICH WOULD EXIST OPEN
JOBS ALONE. COMES OUT TO A
SEVEN POINT NINE BILLION WITH A
B. OPPORTUNITY IN TERMS OF
ANNUAL SALARIES IN THE STATE-
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT FROM
INDUSTRY FROM EDUCATION WITH K.
TWELVE AND HIGHER IF I WANT TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- THE
PARENT AND STUDENT EXPERIENCE.
TO CO .ORG IS AN INTERNATIONAL
A NONPROFIT. FORTY IN THE WEST
THE PERCENT OF WHAT YOU ARE.
AND HAVE COUNSEL CODE BOARD. I
WOULD START LOOKING. AT DATA
AND PARENTS IN AN ADMITTED.
SEVENTY PER. OF PRINCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC
SCHOOL SUPPOSED ACTUALLY ABOUT.
ONE IS OFFERED IN THE- AKA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE- ISSUE IS FUN
ANACT FOR. AND BEING ABLE TO
TEACHERS TO TEACH SCIENCE. WHEN
WE ZOOM OUT NATIONALLY 93% OF
PARENTS WANT THEIR CHILD'S
SCHOOL TO TEACH COMPUTER
SCIENCE BUT ONLY 45% OF PUBLIC
HIGH SCHOOLS NATIONALLY
TEACHER. YOU HEARD THE START
EARLIER 39% I HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. 50% OF AMERICANS
ACCORDING TO GOOGLE GALLUP
SURVEY- RING COMPUTER SCIENCE
IS ONE OF THE TWO MOST
IMPORTANT SUBJECTS TO STUDY
AFTER READING AND WRITING. 75%
OF AMERICANS BELIEVE COMPUTER
SCIENCE IS COOL IN A WAY THAT
IT WASN'T TEN YEARS AGO. AT 67%
OF PARENTS AND 56% OF TEACHERS
BELIEVE COMPUTER SCIENCE SHOULD
BE REQUIRED. TO LEARN- SHOULD
BE REQUIRED AS A COURSE A
COMPUTER SAID SHOULD BE
REQUIRED EXCUSE ME. AND ASKED
DIDN'T TO LEARN COMPUTER
SCIENCE IN HIGH SCHOOL- ARE SIX
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO MAJOR IN
IT AND FOR FEMALE STUDENTS-
THEY ARE TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO MAJOR IF THEY ARE OFFER
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I SUIT GOING BACK TO THE WORK
THAT WE DO HERE- IN CALIFORNIA.
I WE HAVE AN AMAZING
PARTNERSHIP WITH EIGHT
DIFFERENT- PUBLIC OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES OR I NON PROFITS
IN THE STATE. TO OFFER COMPUTER
SCIENCE TRAINING TO THOSE
TEACHERS. IN ORDER TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO WERE WHO WERE
RECEIVING COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION. IN CALIFORNIA ALONE-
CO DOT ORG HIS AT THEIR SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND TEACHERS WHO
HAVE ACCOUNTS AND CO DOT ORG.
IN TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
STUDENTS HAVE ACCOUNTS ON C¡
.ORG. OF STUDENTS USING OUR
CURRICULUM IN THE LAST SCHOOL
YEAR 62% ATTENDED HIGH NEED
SCHOOLS 7% ARE IN RURAL
SCHOOLS. ARE 5043% ARE FEMALE
STUDENTS FIFTY NINE-
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS AGAIN WE
DEFINE THOSE AS- BLOCK- LATINO
OR AT NATIVE AMERICAN AYE OR
HAWAIIAN. WITH THE OUR COULD OR
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE FIFTY NINE
FACILITATORS WORKING ACROSS THE
STATE- AND OUR PARTNERS RANGER
ARE FROM COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. UNIVERSITIES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE I
KNOW WE HAVE HEARD FROM A LOT
OF SPEAKERS THERE'S NOT A LOT
MORE I WOULD LIKE TO ADD APART
FROM. IN ORDER TO INCREASE
EQUITABLE ACCESS EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE ROBUST AND COMPREHENSIVE
POLICIES ARE STARTING IN THE K.
TWELVE SECTOR IN SUPPORTING
TEACHERS BOTH IN SERVICE AND
PRE SERVICE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE TWO MORE
SPEAKERS ON THIS PANEL BEFORE
WE OPEN IT UP- FOR Q. NA FOR
THE FULL PANEL- WE HAVE ELLIE
GARDNER FROM PROJECT LEAD THE
WAY. AND P. EVENT METER A
TEACHER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
SO WE WILL START- WITH ELLIE
GARDNER AS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN GETTING. COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND STEM EDUCATION
CURRICULUM INTO OUR K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS- SO WILL ALL
START WITH ELLIE WELCOME THE
THING JAIL AND AS YOU MENTIONED
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IS AB
CURRICULUM AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROVIDER IN THIS
TIME SPACE. MY NAME IS ALLEY
GARNER AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY I'M
ACTUALLY TAKE A STEP BACK A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER AND
HOPEFULLY ADDRESS SOME
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAD ABOUT
SPARKING INTEREST IN STUDENTS
AND RETAINING STUDENTS IN THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE SPACE. WHAT
WE'VE NOTICED AS WHEN WE'RE
CONFRONTED WITH THE LACK OF
GIRLS THE LACK OF DATA THAT WE
HAVE FOUR. GIRLS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN COMPUTR SCIENCE THERE
IS OFTEN A KNEE JERK REACTION
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES IN HIGH SCHOOL.
WHILE THOSE ARE VERY BENEFICIAL
IN THEIR OWN RIGHT. NEW HIGH
SCHOOL COURSES ALONE WILL NOT
CLOSE THE GAP FOR GIRLS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR IN CALIFORNIA.
STUDENTS MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THEY ARE GOOD AT MATH
OR SCIENCE AT A VERY EARLY AGE.
THINK ABOUT THE FIRST TIME YOU
THOUGHT YOU WEREN'T GOOD AT
SOMETHING. I KNOW IT WAS EARLY
FOR ME. RESEARCH ON STUDENT AT
SELF EFFICACY IN MATH AND
SCIENCE THAT SHOW WAS STARTING
STARTLING REALITY. GIRLS AND
BOYS BEGIN SELF SELECTING OUT
OF THESE SUBJECTS AS EARLY AS
SECOND GRADE. IF STUDENTS
ENCOUNTER COMPUTER SCIENCE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY OFTEN SELF SELECT OUT THEY
DECIDE IT ISN'T FOR THEM
WITHOUT EVEN TRYING IT. WE MUST
ENGAGE STUDENTS IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
ACTUALLY WE SHOULD ENGAGE THEM
IN PRE K. IMAGINE IF WE
SUGGESTED THE KIDS DON'T START
PLAYING BASKETBALL OR BASEBALL
OR SOFTBALL UNTIL NIGHT GREAT.
OR PERHAPS IN MUSIC WE WAITED
UNTIL NINTH GRADE TO HAND OUT
TRUMPETS OR SAXOPHONES ARE
FLEETS AND THEN ATTEMPTED TO BE
A MARCHING BANDS. WE KNOW THAT
SUCCESS IN ATHLETICS AND MUSIC
BEGINS EARLY ON SO WHY WHY ARE
WE FORCING STUDENTS. TO WAIT
SEE COMPUTER SCIENCE UNTIL SO
LATE TO THEIR EDUCATION. TO
THAT END- WE UTILIZE AND
SUGGEST FOCUSING UPON THREE
RESEARCH BASED FINDINGS TO FUEL
AND SUSTAIN EQUITY IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE FIRST COMPUTER SCIENCE
TO BE INTEGRATED AS PART OF THE
NORMAL CLASSROOM CURRICULUM AS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE. SECONDLY
COMPUTER SCIENCE SHOULD BE
TAUGHT AS EARLY AS PRE K. USING
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
PRACTICES AND FINALLY COMPUTER
SCIENCE TO BE TAUGHT AS PART OF
A BROADER EXPOSURE TO CAREERS
AND OPPORTUNITIES BEGINNING IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST COMPUTER SCIENCE
SHOULD BE INCLUDED AS PART IS
THE PART OF THE OVERALL
ELEMENTARY CURRICULUM AND THE
REGULAR CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE.
COMPUTER SCIENCE TO NOT BE A
SINGLE ACTIVITY DONE ONCE A
YEAR. COMPUTER SCIENCE SHOULD
BE AN EXPECTED PART OF THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE EARLY ON
BECAUSE IT NORMALIZES COMPUTER
SCIENCE FOR ALL PREVENTING THAT
NEGATIVE SELF SELECTION THAT
OFTEN IMPACTS GIRLS AND
STUDENTS THE COLORS. IN THEIR
PURSUIT OF COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
STEM. INTEGRATED AN ONGOING
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCES ALSO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS NOT
JUST THOSE WITH ACCESS TO
COMPUTERS AT HOME EXPERIENCE
COMPUTER SCIENCE. EARLY
EXPOSURE TO COMPUTER SCIENCE
USING DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE PRACTICE IS KEY TO
CREATING SUSTAINING INTEREST IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE. RESEARCH THAT
SUGGESTS THAT LEARNING STEM
CONTENT DURING PRESCHOOL YEARS
IS CRITICAL TO LATER SUCCESS IN
SCHOOLS FOR ALL DOMAINS.
INCLUDING READING COMPREHENSION
AND MATHEMATICS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS THAT MEANS
ENGAGING IN LEARNING AND WHAT
FEELS LIKE PLAY- I BROUGHT
TODAY THE CODING MOUSE THAT IS
VERY POPULAR IN THE PRESCHOOL
AND ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SPACE.
BECAUSE. IT'S IMPORTANCE USING
THIS CODING MOUSE USING THIS
CUTTING MOUSE STUDENTS DEVELOP
SPATIAL SENSE BY EXPLORING THE
DIRECTIONAL MOVEMENT OF THE
MOUSE THE IDEAS OF OVER UNDER
THROUGH AND AROUND THIS KIND OF
ACTIVITY HELP STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND COMPUTER SCIENCE
ENCODING EARLY ON AND SEEING
PLAY AS PART OF LESSON PLANNING
WHILE ALSO DEVELOPING SKILLS
LIKE PROBLEM SOLVING CRITICAL
AND CREATIVE THINKING
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION.
FINALLY COMPUTER SCIENCE SHOULD
BE TAUGHT SIMPLY AS A SUBJECT
BUT RATHER AS PART OF A CAREER
EXPLORATION EARLY ON. MOST OF
US WHEN ASKED IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL PROBABLY SAID SOMETHING
LIKE TEACHER DOCTOR OR
POLICEMEN WHILE THAT LIST OFTEN
DOES EXPANDS AWARENESS OF
CAREERS IN THE SKILLED NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER. JOCELYN MACULA OF
JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY IN COMPTON
WAS NAMED THAN- THE KILTIE W.
NATIONAL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER OF THE YEAR AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. IN HER NOMINATION
PAPER A FIFTH GRADE TEACHER A
FIFTH GRADE GIRL WROTE OF MISS
MACULA I NEVER HAD ANY COMPUTER
SCIENCE EXPERIENCE AND BECAUSE
THE MISS MACULA I FEEL I HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE AN
ENGINEER. I AM LEARNING THAT I
AM ABLE TO BE AN ENGINEER EVEN
THOUGH I'M FROM COST. AS THIS
EXAMPLE SHOWS AWARENESS OF THE
SUBJECT AREA IS NOT ENOUGH THIS
STUDENT CLEARLY HAD HEARD ABOUT
COMPUTER SCIENCE SHE HAD HEARD
ABOUT ENGINEERING. THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT STUDENTS
MUST BE EXPOSED TO AND
EXPERIENCE COMPUTER SCIENCE FOR
THEMSELVES EARLY ON. WITHOUT
EXPOSURE AND EXPERIENCE MANY
STUDENTS ASSUME THEY CAN'T
PURSUE THAT SUBJECT. AND OUR
CAREER. THE SAYING IS YOU CAN'T
BE WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE. IT
APPLIES HERE. STUDENTS NEED TO
EXPERIENCE COMPUTER SCIENCE IN
THE ON A REGULAR CLASSROOM
SETTING EARLY ON. THEY NEED TO
EXPERIENCE COMPUTER SCIENCE
HANDS ON AND THEY NEED TO SEE
WHAT A COMPUTER SCIENTIST IS
AND WHAT A COMPUTER SCIENTIST
DOES. WE DON'T WANT STUDENTS TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE A GIRL
BECAUSE THEY ARE STUDENT COLOR
OR THEIR FROM A CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT THEY CAN'T
FLOURISH AND COMPUTER SCIENCE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WITH.
THIS WHOLE THEY THIS WHOLE
HEARING WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT TEACHERS AND WHAT
TEACHERS SHOULD TEACH IN. A
WHAT GRADE LEVEL- AND SO I'M
EXCITED TO HEAR FROM A TEACHER-
AND WE HAVE P. EVENT METER HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER- SHE'S BEEN
TEACHING SCIENCE FOR OVER
THE UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE OF BEING
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER
COORDINATOR- AND SCIENCE
DEPARTMENT CHAIR AT MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
IN RIVERSIDE. WELCOME PIA THANK
YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE THREE
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR-
CONVENING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING AND INVITING ME TO
PROVIDE AN- EDUCATOR'S
PERSPECTIVE. IN NAM ENSURING
ACCESS AND EQUITY TO STEM
COURSES. INCLUDING COMPUTER
SCIENCE FOR STUDENTS IN AT TO
SUCCEED IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. AS CHAIR OF THE
CURRICULUM INSTRUCTIONS
COMMITTEE AT C. CASE POLICY
MAKING BODY THE STATE COUNCIL
OF EDUCATION. WE HAVE LONG
STANDING ORGAN ORGANIZATIONAL
POLICY EMPHASIZING CTA SUPPORT
FOR STRONG STEM PROGRAMS. THIS
MORNING I WILL TALK ABOUT
ACCESS TO STAND FOR ALL
STUDENTS PARTICULAR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS. AND WASTE A
STEM EDUCATION COULD BE
IMPROVED. CDA BELIEVES ALL
STUDENTS SHALL HAVE ACCESS TO A
STANDARD BATES COLLEGE AND
CAREER CURRICULUM TO PREPARE
SOME FOR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND LEADS THEM TO
MEANINGFUL. AND INFORM CORRECT
CHOICES. THE FUTURE OF OUR
COUNTRY DEPENDS ON TODAY
STUDENTS BE TOMORROW'S
INNOVATORS. FOR THIS REASON
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS NEED
SYSTEMIC ONGOING ACCESS TO
STEM. ACROSS THE CURRICULUM IN
GRADES T. K. TWELVE. STEM IS
NOT CONSISTENTLY IMPLEMENTED
AND THERE'S NO COHERENCY FROM
DISTRICT TO DISTRICT OR SCHOOL
TO SCHOOL WITHIN THE DISTRICT.
FOR EXAMPLE MOST DISTRICTS
STARTER STEM PROGRAMS AND
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
DEPENDING ON THEIR GRANTS OR A
ACADEMIES. MOST OFTEN IN
PROGRAMS ARE NOT IN SO IN SAID
AND- IN SOME. DISTRICTS HAVE
USED THE STEM EDUCATION
PLATFORM TO LURE STUDENTS BACK
FROM- CHARTER SCHOOLS. IF STEM
EDUCATION IS A FOCUS OF THE
DISTRICT MOST ACTIVITIES ARE
AFTER SCHOOL RATHER THAN WOVEN
INTO THE REGULAR SCHOOL DAY.
EVEN THOUGH COMMON CORE STATE
STANDARDS IN MATH AND NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS
LEND THEMSELVES TO TEACHING
STEM DISTRICT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR ELEMENTARY
TEACHERS IS NOT ENOUGH TO GIVE
THEM THE EXPERTISE. TO
INCORPORATE SALMON THEIR
CURRICULUM MANY ELEMENTARY
TEACHERS WANT TO TEACH SAN
BASED IN KOREA LEARNING BUT OUR
PUSH TO EMPHASIZE ENGLISH AND
MATH SPECIFIC TO THE DISTRICT
ADOPTED CURRICULUM. TEACHERS
ARE CONCERNED WOULDN'T EVEN
EVEN ACCESS SYSTEM FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE FOR
EXAMPLE A MY HIGH SCHOOL
SPECIAL ED AS WELL AS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS ARE PREVENTED
FROM TAKING SPECIFIC STEM
CURRICULUM. BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO TAKE MANDATORY CLASSES. MANY
DISTRICTS HAVE PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE THAT PREVENT THE STUDENTS
FROM ACCESSING STEMMED CLASSES.
OTHER ISSUES HAVE TO DO WITH
THE LACK OF TRANSPORTATION FOR
STUDENTS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO ATTEND THE STEM
SCHOOLS IN WHICH INFILL TRIPS I
DEPENDED ON AVAILABILITY OF
BUSES DURING THE DAY OR NO
FUNDING FOR ANY. TYPE OF
ENRICHMENT TO HAVE A MODEL STEM
EDUCATION FOR ALL STUDENTS WE
NEED TO BEGIN WITH HOW WE
EDUCATE OUR NEW TEACHERS COMING
INTO THE PROFESSION. THEY NEED
TO HAVE A FOUNDATION FOR
UNDERSTANDING OF CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD FOSTER
STEM EDUCATION IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. THERE SHOULD BE
WASTE FOR STUDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE DIFFERENT STEM
FIELDS BY MEANT. SHALL
SHADOWING FIELD TRIPS A PRINTER
AN INTERNSHIP OP. THERE SHOULD
BE A PARTNER BETWEEN DISTRICTS.
AND BUSINESSES TO FOSTER
STUDENT INTEREST IN THE STEM
FIELDS. STUDENTS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ACCESS STEM CORRECT
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION AND
COMPUTER BECAUSE- IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OR A FOUR YEAR DEGREE
WITH A CAREER PIPELINE FOR
GRADUATING STUDENTS IN THE STEM
INDUSTRY. THE MODEL WE HAVE NOW
IS NOT ENOUGH TO SERVICE ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY
STUDENTS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO ENSURE THAT ALL OUR
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE A QUALITY
STEM EDUCATION. THERE'S NEED TO
BE A SYSTEMIC PARADIGM SHIFT
THAT INSTITUTIONALIZED STEM
EDUCATION FOR TKA TWELFTH THIS
WILL NEED TO BE SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
ED. TO DISTRICTS ENSURING ALL
STUDENTS HAVE EQUAL ACCESS AND
MONETARY SUPPORT NO MATTER
WHICH PART OF TOWN THEY LIVED
IN. STARTING STEM EDUCATION AND
SECONDARY GRADES IS TO LET.
CHILDREN ARE NATURALLY CURIOUS
AND THIS SHOULD BE FOSTERED AT
A YOUNG AGE WHICH MEANS STEM
EDUCATION SHOULD BE STARTING AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. IN CLOSING
CTA. RESHAPES THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR- YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND THE STEM ISSUES AND IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS A POLICY ISSUES
DISCUSSED TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
LEAVE YOU ACTUALLY WITH A- THAT
CALIFORNIA EDUCATOR. FOR THE
JANUARY ISSUE ADD THIS INCLUDES
SECTIONS OF THE TEACHER
INNOVATORS ON PAGES SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY NINE. ABOUT TEACHER
SUCCESSFULLY TEACHING STEM
COURSES AND INSPIRING STERN
ACROSS THE STATE WE NEED MORE
THIS EXEMPLARY TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER WORK FORCE
TO ENSURE ALL OF THE STUDENTS
HAVE THIS TYPE OF EXPERIENCE IN
THEIR CLASSROOM. EVERY MINUTE
OF THE DAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT
TEACHERS ON THIS PANEL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SINCE OUR LAST
PANEL I REALLY ENJOYED THE- THE
KIND OF I FELT LIKE THE BOTH
SIDES LIKE IT'S WE NEED TO
START EARLY AND IT'S NOT TOO
LATE YEAH. I LOVED HEARING AT
ALL AT THE SAME TIME RIGHT HAVE
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN A STEM
EDUCATOR FOR YEARS ALWAYS
FOCUSED ON YOUNGER KIDS. I ALSO
WORKED AT CAL TECH ACTS- BUT
THE KIDS THAT WENT THERE WERE
ALREADY INTERESTED AND WE WERE
JUST FOCUSING ON MAKING THEM
SUCCESSFUL- IN THE FUTURE- SO I
REALLY ENJOYED THIS- BUT BEFORE
I ASK MY QUESTION I'D LIKETO
OPEN IT UP TO. THE COMMITTEE SO
MR OBERNOLTE. SO I THOUGHT IT
WAS A FAST NAY THIS. OF WHEN
THE APPROACH TIME TO START
EDUCATION AND COMPUTER SCIENCES
YOU HEARD ME OUT REALLY THREE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS WITH. THIS
GARDENER SAYING BEFORE
KINDERGARTEN MISSPENT METER
SAYING YOU KNOW IN IT-
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND DOCTOR
KLAUS SAYING IF NOT. I MEAN.
IT'S NOT A BAD THING TO START
SOON BUT YOU CERTAINLY CAN
START LATER AS WELL- BUT I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT. THE
DISCONNECT HERE IS. A FAILURE
TO FIND DEFINE EXACTLY WHAT WE
MEAN WHEN WE SAY THE A WHAT IS
COMPUTER SCIENCE WHAT IS CODING
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE. A PRE
KINDERGARTEN STUDENT AND SAY
LET'S TALK ABOUT PYTHON RIGHT-
SO WHAT WE'RE TEACHING IS VERY
DIFFERENT I THINK IT'S AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A CODER. IS VERY
DIFFERENT WHEN I LEARNED TO
PROGRAM. IT WAS CLEAR THAT
CODING MATT TAKING A-
PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE AND
WRITING COMPUTER CODE BUT- AS
COMPUTER SCIENCE HAS EVOLVED
YOU KNOW OBJECT ORIENTATION
MEANS THAT REALLY ARE USING
CODE THAT OTHER PEOPLE WRITE.
SCRIPTING LANGUAGES MEAN THAT
REALLY YOU'RE NOT WRITING A
PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE AT ALL AND
NOW I MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SKILLS THAT WE TEACH TO
STUDENTS. EVEN DOING WORK IN AN
EXCEL SPREADSHEET OR DOING
ADVANCED SEARCH IN GOOGLE I
MEAN THAT IS CODING THERE
REALLY IS THAT IS PROGRAMMING
SO I MEAN I REALLY THINK THAT
THE ANSWER TO THIS YOU KNOW
THIS. THIS DOESN'T- IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT CODING
MEANS A LOT MORE THAN JUST
WRITING LINES OF COMPUTER CODE.
AND YOU KNOW JUST TEACHING A
PRE KINDERGARTEN STUDENT HOW TO
USE A COMPUTER TO PERFORM TASKS
TO GET INFORMATION YOU KNOW
THAT IS. PREPARING THEM FOR A
CAREER IN PROGRAMMING. SO IF I
MAY EIGHT I THINK THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- WE
INTERCHANGEABLY USE THE WORD
CODING IN COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
OFTEN TIMES THAT- ACTUALLY. UP
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE COMPOSED AT
CODING IS A PART OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE BUT NOT THE ONLY PART
AND SO WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
THOSE THINGS- BROKEN APART AN-
IMPORTANT I. IN ANSWER TO YOUR
ABOUT. A STUDENTS LET ME JUST
READ WHAT WE WHAT WE UTILIZE A
PRE K. C. CAN UNDERSTAND. YOU
SAID THAT REALLY COOL NOW
BECAUSE IT'S COLORFUL AND I
BROUGHT WITH ME SOME. STUDENTS
DIFFICULT SPATIAL SENSE WHEN
THE ACTIVITIES THAT IT EXPLORE
CORRECTIONAL MOVEMENT OVER
UNDER THROUGH AROUND BUT THEN
AGAIN TO DEVELOP CODING SKILLS
AS THEY PLAN UP. WITH CREATE
WEARABLE CODE AND CODE AN
INTERACTIVE ROBOTIC DEVICE.
KATE AMOUNTS. I THINK IN TO
PASS CAN CREATE. CODE THAT THE
LEAD TO THE LOOK OF A OF A
HIDDEN ITEM. AND SO THOSE KIND
OF. SPARK EARLY ON SO IT'S A-
THE WRITING OF THE CODE THAT
YOU'RE TALK ABOUT. BUT
EXPLORING HOW. COMPUTER SCIENCE
CODE CAN BE A PART OF EVERYDAY
LIFE AND WHAT THEY USE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY I THINK
THOSE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT AND
USING IT IN. DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE- ACTIVITIES IS KEY
TO ENSURING THAT THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN. SO I SO FIRST OF ALL I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
LEARNING. NOT JUST CODING BUT
THE BROADER SET OF
COMPUTATIONAL THINKING SKILLS.
BUT I WANT TO FOCUS RIGHT NOW
ON A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
POPULATION. A I AND DATA
SCIENCE AND COMPUTER SCIENCE
ARE CHANGING THE WORLD WE LIVE
IN. AND WITHIN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS THEY'RE ALL KINDS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW LONG AFTER
THEY GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE WHO
WERE GOING NEED TO LEARN THE
SKILLS SO WHEN WE THE WHOLE
POINT ABOUT I THINK WHAT WE'RE
ALL SAYING. IS THAT THERE ARE
WAYS TO MAKE THIS KNOWLEDGE
EXCESS ACCESSIBLE AN
INTERESTING AND HIGHLY
MOTIVATING FOR PEOPLE OF ANY
AGE WITH THE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PRE K. STUDENT. A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENT COLLEGE STUDENT
GRADUATE STUDENT AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I MENTIONED THE- POST OP
PROGRAM WERE STARTING. I I'M AN
EXAMPLE OF SOMEBODY WHO GOT HER
PHD AND MATHEMATICS NEVER TOOK
A COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE NEVER
WROTE A LINE OF CODE.
DISCOVERED WITHIN THE YEAR
AFTER MY PHD THAT THE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MATHEMATICIANS WHO ALSO COULD
DO COMPUTER SCIENCE WERE LIKE A
HUNDRED TIMES WHATTHEY WERE
FROM ETHNIC MATHEMATICAL PH DIS
WEB BACK. STARTED A SECOND PHD
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE GOT HIRED
BY ONE OF THE TOP TEN
DEPARTMENTS IN THE WORLD.
LITERALLY NINE MONTHS AFTER I
STARTED. OKAY THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE ABOUT. BEING ABLE TO
LEARN WHAT THE WORLD NEEDS AND
I THINK WHAT WE'RE ALL SAYING
IS NUMBER ONE. ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN NEED IT. ALL OF OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS NEED IT. ALL
OF OUR ADULTS INCLUDING PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT CODING ANYMORE.
THEY ARE GOING TO NEED THIS.
AND WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS WE
HAVE TO GET MUCH BETTER AT
PROVIDING ACCESS. TO EVERYONE.
FOR MORE PLEASE- WE ARE NOT AT
C¡ DOT ORG WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
CREATE- THE OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCESS SO THAT THE STUDENTS
WILL BE GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL GOING INTO COLLEGE TO BE
COMPUTER SCIENCE MAJORS NOR ARE
WE SAYING THAT EVERY STUDENT
NEEDS TO BE A COMPUTER
PROGRAMMER OR ENGINEER BUT IT
WE HAVE SEEN THAT EVERY FIELD I
WE HAVE NOT FOUND A SINGLE
FIELD WHERE AN UNDERSTANDING OF
COMPUTING AND AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE CONCEPTS OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE LIKE COMPUTATIONAL
THINKING. ARE NOT NECESSARY
THAT'S NOT TO SAY EVERY SINGLE
JOB WILL REQUIRE THAT BUT EVERY
FIELD HAS- A COMPONENT THAT
REQUIRES UNDERSTANDING IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE- THE LAST
POINT I'LL MAKE IS WHEN OUR
FOUNDER STARTED CO DOT ORG HE
USED TO SAY IN HIS INITIAL
TALKS YOU UNLESS YOU'RE DRIVING
TRUCKER FLIPPING BURGERS YOU
DON'T NEED YOU'RE GOING TO NEED
TO HAVE A BASIC UNDERSTANDING
OF COMPUTING AND COMPUTER
SCIENCE BUT EVEN NOW IN THE
TIME AUTOMATION WE HAVE.
AUTOMATED TRUCKS DRIVING EVERY
DAY FROM ARIZONA TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- THAT ARE SEMI
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES WE HAVE NO
IN MANY OF THE LARGEST FAST
FOOD INDUSTRY'S COMPUTERIZED
BURGER FLIPPERS REPLACING THE
JOBS OF THE MOST ENTRY LEVEL
JOBS SO WHAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GIVING STUDENTS
THE TOOLS WHO MAY NOT BE GOING
TO COLLEGE MAY BE PURSUING
SERVICE INDUSTRY CAREERS- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE OTHER
OPTIONS TO USE THAT COMPUTERS
WELL LET ME ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU
SAID IN YOUR COMMENTS YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT. OF THE HIGH WAGE
HIGH WAGES IN THE INFORMATION
INDUSTRY AND THE NEED TO-
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE
UNDERSERVED UNITIES GET ACCESS
TO THOSE WAGES WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE'RE
ALL IN. WITH ABOUT YOU KNOW
TRISTE. FEET OF INFORMATION TO.
IS THE JUST. IN WORKER PRO.
BETWEEN PEOPLE THAT ARE REALLY
REALLY GOOD AT IT AND PEOPLE
THAT YOU KNOW ARE PRETTY GOOD
AT IT SO I MEAN TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE I HAVE SOFTWARE
ENGINEERS THAT WORK FOR ME.
THAT ARE TEN TIMES MORE
PRODUCTIVE THAN OTHERS THE WORK
FOR ME SO IT CREATES AN
INTERESTING DILEMMA BECAUSE-
HOW DO YOU. CREATE COMPENSATION
EQUITY IN THAT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE- I MEAN.
SOCIETY WOULDN'T SAY IT'S FAIR
TO PAY ONE PERSON TEN TIMES AS
MUCH AS ANOTHER. BUT IF THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY IS TEN TIMES
HIGHER IF YOU DON'T PAY THEM AT
LEAST TWO OR THREE TIMES AS
MUCH THEY'RE GOING TO GO WORK
FOR SOMEBODY ELSE SO. YOU KNOW
I WONDER YOU CREATE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES BUT AT THE SAME
TIME YOU'RE EXACERBATING INCOME
INEQUALITY WITHIN THOSE
COMMUNITIES HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
AS A SOCIETY. GRAPPLE WITH THAT
PROBLEM. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND- OF THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU ARE IMPLYING. ARE YOU ARE
YOU SAYING THAT PEOPLE FROM
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT PERFORMING AS ON OR NOT
OKAY. A LITTLE CONFUSED NO I
MEAN I MEAN THAT IF YOU TAKE.
IF YOU TAKE IN A POPULATION OF
PROGRAMMERS IN A PROGRAM IS
UNIQUE IF YOU HIRE A COUPLE
PEOPLE TO- YOU KNOW BUILD A
WIDGET ON ASSEMBLY LINE YOU
KNOW ONE MIGHT BE TWO OR THREE
TIMES AS MO AT MOST AS
PRODUCTIVE AS THE NEXT ONE AND
USUALLY. THAT INCREASE THE
PRODUCTIVITY INCREASES WITH
EXPERIENCE- PROGRAMMING IS VERY
MUCH NOT THAT WAY THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE JUST. THE JUST
BRAINS ARE WIRED TO WORK THAT
WAY RIGHT. AND YOU KNOW THEY
AND THEY COULD THEY COULD BE
TEN TIMES AS PRODUCTIVE AS THE
PERSON NEXT TO THEM- SO I JUST
WONDER. HOW DO WE A SOCIETY
GRAPPLE WITH THAT PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT IT YOU KNOW WHAT. I
WANT YOU KNOW SO RIGHT NOW ONE
OF THE THINGS WE KNOW IS THAT-
MOST OF THE TOP SOFTWARE
DEVELOPING. ACES ARE USING PAIR
PROGRAMMING AND USING IT
BECAUSE IT A CREATES LIKE MOST
OF THE EFFORT IN A COMPLICATED
SOFTWARE SYSTEM GOES INTO
DEBUGGING I MEAN. MAYBE LESS
TRUE IN THE GAME INDUSTRY BUT
DEFINITELY FOR- YOU KNOW LARGE
SCALE SYSTEMS AND SO WHAT YOU
REALLY WANT TO ACHIEVE IT'S NOT
THAT YOU CAN WRITE THE CODE
FAST BUT YOU CAN WRITE THE CODE
AT A REASONABLE SPEED BUT IT
HAS MANY FEWER ERRORS. AND SO
THERE ARE A BUNCH OF WHAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
IS THAT PAIR PROGRAMMING DOES
MUCH BETTER AND ACTUALLY DOES
BETTER WITH PEOPLE WHOSE BRAINS
ARE WIRED DIFFERENTLY TOGETHER.
AND SO THIS WHOLE IDEA AND YOU
KNOW I HAPPEN TO HAVE A SON
WHO- IS AN AMAZING SOFTWARE
ARCHITECT SOFTWARE ENGINEER IN
WHO CAN WRITE REALLY QUICKLY.
BUT ONE OF THINGS THAT'S BEEN
INTERESTING TO ME IN AND
WATCHING HIS CAREER IS THAT.
THEY'RE NOW REALLY FOCUSING ON
GETTING PEOPLE WITH DIVERSE
SKILLS TO COME AND WORK
TOGETHER SO ONE OF THINGS WE
EMPHASIZE IT MIGHT IS FIRST OF
ALL A LOT OF OUR SOFTWARE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMMING BECAUSE
THAT'S BEST PRACTICE NOW. BUT
ALSO AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
EFFORT IS ON TRAINING. OUR
STUDENTS TO WORK IN DIVERSE
TEAMS. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS
ARE PERSPECTIVES AND I'M NOT
TALKING NESTLE ABOUT RACE OR
GENDER THOUGH THAT'S PART OF
IT. ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
IS ANOTHER PART OF IT THEY
BRING DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
AND THAT CREATES BETTER
SOLUTIONS SO YOU KNOW THAT.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT WE HAVE
MAJOR ISSUES ABOUT PAY EQUITY I
MEAN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
HAPPENING AT MODE RIGHT NOW IS
YOUR HAVE TO MAJOR IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE TO GET PAID A HUNDRED
FIFTY K. PER YEAR WHEN YOU
GRADUATE. YOU JUST HAVE TO TAKE
THE FIRST THREE COURSES IN
SEQUENCE AND GOOGLE OR
MICROSOFT OR- APPLE FOR WHOEVER
WILL HIRE YOU. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE DISCOVERED THAT THOSE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO DO JUST
FINE THE SOFTWARE ENGINEERING
POSITION. MEANING THE BY OR
MAJOR SINK. PHYSICS AND-
ENGINEER AND NOT GO TO GRAD
SCHOOL OR NOT GOING INTO OTHER
AREAS ANYMORE BECAUSE- THERE'S
JUST THIS. VACUUM SUCKING
PEOPLE INTO SOFTWARE
ENGINEERING THINGS SO THESE ARE
LOTS OF PROBLEMS TO SOLVE. I
THINK THE REASON I'M SO HAPPY
TO BE HERE TO BE TALKING. TO
YOU IS BECAUSE- I DO THINK
CALIFORNIA IT NEEDS TO GET OUT
IN FRONT OF IT. WE CERTAINLY
HAVE AN AWFUL LOT OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITIES IN OUR SCHOOLS. WE
HAVE A LOT OF ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. THIS IS A PLACE WHERE
IF WE REALLY WANT OUR TECH
ECONOMY TO CONTINUE AND RIGHT
NOW EVERYTHING'S A TECH
HEALTHCARE IS A TECH ECONOMY
ENTERTAINMENT TO TECH ECONOMY
EVERYTHING IS A TECH CON WE
REALLY WANT TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE COUNTRY IN DOING THAT WE'VE
GOT TO FIX WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES
AND IN. OUR ADULT EDUCATION FOR
TOTALLY TOTALLY AGREE WITH THAT
AND YOU KNOW JUST- WILL BE A
LOOPING IT BACK TO THE
DISCUSSION WE WERE HAVING YOU
KNOW IF. IF OUR GOAL YOU KNOW
IS TO INCREASE PROSPERITY THEN-
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
AREN'T WE- IDENTIFY THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
I MEAN THE OTHER'S GIGS. THE
EXISTENCE OF THESE I MEAN JUST
BE CALLED SUPER PROGRAMMERS
WRITE THESE THESE PEOPLE WITH
VERY HIGH PRODUCTIVITY IN
SOFTWARE ENGINEERING- THOSE
PEOPLE ARE ABOUT I HAVE BEEN
UNDER. THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHERE THE SUPPLY AS AND
SO THAT'S WHY I THINK WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON THEM BUT IT'S GOING
TO BE AN INTERESTING PROBLEM
FOR. SOCIETY TO SOLVE YOU KNOW
HOW TO HOW TO BALANCE THIS-
HAVE COMPENSATION AGAINST
PRODUCTIVITY BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE ARMS AROUND. LIKE TO GIVE
YOU HAVE MISSED WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THAT SYSTEMIC AS IN A
PARADIGM SHIFT I THINK IT'S
WHAT ELLIE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
MOST OFTEN NOW WHEN WE GO INTO
A CLASSROOM. THERE'S NOT EVEN A
SENSE OF PLAY AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN LOWER GRADES BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO FOCUSED OF WANTING
TO. DO CERTAIN THINGS AT THE
SAME TIME FOR EVERY SINGLE
CLASSROOM. THERE'S NOT TIME FOR
THEM TO KIND OF EXPLORE. IN NOT
THE PART TO ME LIKE WHEN I WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL WHICH WAS I
GRADUATED IN NINETY THREE IN
HIGH SCHOOL BUT- I WAS ABLE TO
DO THAT. I WAS ABLE TO DO THAT
IN MIDDLE AND ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DEAR STIS SETS OF ALL. IN WHICH
HIGH NEED TO PUT IT IN BASED ON
WE KNOW PUTTING IN COMMON CORE-
STATE SANDERS WE DID AND GSS
BUT WE STILL ARE CONSTRAINED AS
TEACHERS TO EXPLORE DIFFERENT
INCLUDE HOW TO. IMPART THAT
MISSION THAT'S PART OF PLAY.
LIKE WHAT'S CONSTRAINT PART OF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
PASSION OR JUST A JOB BECAUSE
THAT THERE IS THAT. WHERE HEY I
COULD GET HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO I'LL JUST
GO AHEAD AND GO INTO COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND THEN YOU HAVE THIS
ONE PERSON THAT DAY LEAD LIVE
AND BREATHE IT. SOLD WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO IMPART THAT PASSION
FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT. BUT WE CAN'T IF WE DON'T
GIVE OUR TEACHERS CHANCE TO
CHANGE THE WITH THE WITH THE IN
THE CLASSROOM. TO IT FUN FOR
THIS. IT'S A THAT TO ME I THINK
IS THE- THING. THAT WE DO
BECAUSE THEY WALK IN THE YOU
SAID G
LLEGE WAY IT'S A BOOK. IT'S
ABOUT THE BOOK IT'S ABOUT THE
BIGGER PICTURE AND I THINK THAT
THE PART THAT WE NEED TO KIND
OF GRAPPLE WITH I'M WE CAN
CHANGE THAT AND- KEY. TWELVE
THANK YOU SO OF. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. PETRIE-NORRIS SOMEWHAT
PICKING UP ON THAT YES IT WILL
YOU YOU BOTH MENTIONED I'M LEON
MENTIONED. SOME OF THE REALLY
HUGE HUGE AND FUNDAMENTAL
CHALLENGES WERE FACING AND YOUR
K. THROUGH TWELVE CLASSROOMS
AND- IT KIND OF COMES DOWN TO
THE FACT THAT WE ARE STILL IN
MANY WAYS. EDUCATING OUR
STUDENTS FOR THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION RIGHT RIGHT AND YOU
KNOW TO DO THOSE KINDS OF JOBS
AND- I'M IN THE PATH FROM WHERE
WE ARE. TOO HIGH A CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT THAT ACTUALLY
PREPARES OUR STUDENTS IN AN
INTEGRATED AT AN INCLUSIVE WAY
FOR THE JOB. TOMORROW AND THERE
IS I YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
THAT WE NEED TO DO AND YOU YOU
MENTIONED MANY OF THOSE THINGS.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IF
YOU I'M YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO TELL US ONE THING. ONE THING
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE US DO
YOU THIS YEAR WHAT WOULD IT BE.
I'M STARTING WITH. ME FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
PARTICULAR- THEY SHOULD HAVE A
HUB. THAT ALL EITHER- BY GRADE
LEVELS BECAUSE WHEN IT IS
ACTUALLY ANTED TEACHERS
ACTUALLY SAID THIS TO ME. WE'RE
DATE THEY COULD GO AND
EVERYTHING THAT HAS TO DO WITH
STEM IS THAT. THEN I'D AS A
TEACHER COULD COME IN AND LOOK
AT WHAT THEY HAVE AND THEN
BRING IN STUDENTS SAN AND THEN
JUST HAVE THEM EXPLORE. INSTILL
IN ESSENCE INCORPORATING
READING WRITING. MATHEMATICS
BUT NOW IT'S IN PLAY. OUR
CLASSROOM DOES NOT LOOK LIKE
WHAT YOU SEE IN GOOGLE WHERE
IT'S LIKE STILL EITHER ALL
CHAIRS DESK YOU KNOW IN LINE
SOMETHING WE ARE CHANGING
THERE'S ARE THERE ARE TEACHERS
THAT HAVE CHANGED THAT WHERE WE
HAVE MOVABLE YOU KNOW I'M I
GUESS. WE'LL SEE THAT'S CORRECT
BUT THE PROBLEM THOUGH IS THAT
THERE'S NO MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT FOR EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL. SOLD MOST OFTEN
TEACHERS WOULD ACTUALLY PAY ON
THEIR OWN MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT. SO I. IF I WERE GONNA
TRY AND DO ONE THING I WOULD.
IMPROVE THE PAY AND THE RESPECT.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE TEACHING AT
ALL LEVELS. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
REALLY BIG PROBLEMS RIGHT NOW
IS THAT IF YOU'RE PAID TO BE AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER IS
SIXTY THOUSAND PER YEAR I DON'T
KNOW I'M GUESSING- I KNOW IT'S
HIGHER IN SOME PLACES. AND IF
YOU'RE PAID TO BE STARTING A
SOFTWARE ENGINEER IS A HUNDRED
FIFTY K. I MEAN EVEN JUST EIGHT
UNIVERSITY LEVELS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS. ONE OF OUR
GRADUATES CAN GET A HUNDRED
FIFTY K. SOMEBODY WHO GOES AND
GETS A PEACH TEA. AND THEN
COMES BACK AND TEACHES IS GONNA
BE SOMEPLACE BETWEEN A HUNDRED
AND FIVE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY K.
SO SIGNIFICANTLY LESS. SO YOU
YOU KNOW. I REALLY THINK THAT
WE NEED TO. WE NEED TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE WHO LOVE TO
TEACH AND MOTIVATE PEOPLE FOR
THEIR THEIR TEACHING ADULT
STUDENTS OR TEACHING COULD PRE
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE TO CHOOSE CAREERS AND I
REALLY THINK RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
CERTAINLY NOT THE OUR STATE IN
THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF HOW WE
PAY OUR TEACHERS. BUT I YOU
KNOW I'M- I GREW UP IN CANADA.
WHEN I WAS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
BRITISH COLUMBIA THE STARTING
SALARY FOR A FACULTY MEMBER IN
THE FLOPPY OF EDUCATION WAS THE
SAME AS THE SALARY FOR SOMEBODY
WHO BEEN TEACHING FOR. EIGHT
YEARS. SO THEY WERE AND IT WAS
REGARDED AS YOU KNOW IF YOU
WERE AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER. AND YOU WERE DOING A
GREAT JOB YOU WERE JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS A FACULTY MEMBER
AT THE UNIVERSITY. SO I THINK
THAT WE NEED A SHIFT IN TERMS
OF OUR VALUE SYSTEM AND THAT
ALSO ENTAILS A SHIFT IN TERMS
OF. PAY SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA
TALK A LOT ABOUT FUNDING
CLEARLY- I WOULD LOOK TO LAST
YEAR'S- COMPUTER SCIENCE
STANDARDS THAT WERE ADOPTED BY
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THEM WAS THE CAN'T BE A MANDATE
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM AND SO
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE
FUND THOSE THINGS AND
IMPLEMENTS THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE STANDARDS.
INTO THE CLASSROOMS ON A DAILY
BASIS THAT BECAUSE IT'S AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE IT IT ISN'T
CURRENTLY. ROCK IN CLASSROOMS A
LOT OF THOSE STANDARDS INCLUDE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT OF ENSURING
THAT THERE ITS ACTIVITY BASED-
PLAY LIKE THINGS SO THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT COMPUTER
SCIENCE LOOKS LIKE BUT YOU
CAN'T REQUIRE. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE THE CLASSROOM WITHOUT
IT THE FUNDING. HI IF I COULD
DO A MAY. WAND AND THE
ASPIRATIONAL OUT. THE POLICY
ITEM THAT COULD BE DONE IT
WOULD BE- MANDATING AND FUNDING
ALL PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA TEACH COMPUTER
SCIENCE NOT TO SAY EVERY
STUDENT HAS TO TAKE IT BUT-
EVERY SINGLE PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL
MUST OFFER COMPUTER SCIENCE.
THAT IS GOING TO BE HARD TO DO
IN ONE SESSION- IS SO IS THAT
IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
REALISTIC AND MANY OF US IN
THIS ROOM ARE ADVOCATING FOR IS
INCREASING THE FUNDING FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TEACHERS. AND PROVIDING AS
INCENTIVE TO TEACHERS. SO
MAKING SURE IT'S NOT JUST.
GIVING THAT THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE FUNDING BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE YOU'RE COVERING THE
TEACHER. I AM. A SUBSTITUTE OF
TIME AWAY FROM THE CLASSROOM.
POTENTIALLY OBSCENE REQUESTED
TO A REALLY GREAT JOB TEXAS AND
IN NEW YORK AMONG THEM. OUR
ACTUALLY GIVE TEACHER IN TERMS
OF THOUSAND. FOR TWO. THAT
PRESSURE TO. COURSES GREAT. THE
YOU MY. I WITH TO CONTINUE THIS
JUST IN FOR OUR- AND THE CITY
THEY ARE NINE THAT CAN'T BUT I
OF BY HAVE ONE FINE QUESTION
BEFORE I ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
COMMON I BUT A IT'S FOR MISS
VAN METER YOU KNOW WE- YOU KNOW
AS- FROM YOUR PURSE. AS A T. IN
A REF OF THE CAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION HOW YOU KNOW DO YOU
HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS ON
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHER
SHORTAGE SOUL- WE ACTUALLY-
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE- OF
ACTUAL. OF WASTE OR A PIPELINE
TO DO THAT I KNOW THAT IN OUR
OWN C. P. D. OR IN THIS CASE
THE- CREDENTIAL AND
PROFESSIONAL- COMMITTEE THAT WE
HAVE. WE ARE LOOKING INTOTHAT
AND WE HAVE CREDENTIALS DAD'S
ARE ARE ALREADY IN PLACE AND I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IS FOR HOW THE TEACHERS TO KIND
OF GO IN AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT EITHER GET A
SUPPLEMENTARY CONVENTIONAL OR
SOMETHING TO CONNECT A
CORPORATION THAT THEY HAVE IT
UPDATED VERSION OF WHAT WE NEED.
OKAY YEAH BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
YOU TO BE A COULD SCIENCE KNOW
OUR DON'T NEED TO SIGN CORRECT
I MEAN ALL OF YOU HAVE BROUGHT
UP IN. IF WE WANT TO INCREASE
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN CALIFORNIA
AT ALL LEVELS WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON. GETTING THE PEOPLE
INTERESTED AND PREPARED TO
TEACH YOU KNOW I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS THEIR DREAM
JOB TO TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE
EITHER AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEVEL K. TWELVE- BUT THERE IS.
THERE IS IT LIKE A PATH WAIT
RIGHT ROUTE IT'S CLEAR TO
EVERYONE AND I THINK AS
LEGISLATORS THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN. WORK TOWARDS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU
THAT ARE HERE TODAY RIGHT AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY TWO
BILLS. THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THAT CAME FROM THE LARGEST
CHAIR SO I KNOW THAT THAT JUST
KINDA CAME IN AND SO SEE. ON
THE COMPANY. OF OR
CREDENTIALING IS LOOK AT THAT.
SO WE ALWAYS WORK TOGETHER
BECAUSE WE- WE ALWAYS WANT
WHAT'S BEST FOR STUDENTS AS
WELL ART AS OUR TEACHERS SO IN
THIS CASE I THINK NAPA. ON
INCOME. THEN A WHAT. FOR ALL.
GRAY THANK. YOU SO MUCH TO ALL
OF OUR HAND TO. I LOOK FOR TO
WORKING EVERY TO COULD
CALIFORNIA'S CAN. OUT. I NOW
MOVE TO POP VOMIT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SINCE. PEOPLE THAT ARE
WAITING TO COMMENT ON IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC. A
LINE UP AT THE MIKE SO YOUR
NAME AND ORG. AND TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF TIME- PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTE SO.
THE RIGHT ARM MARK EPSTEIN
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION NETWORK LAST YEAR I
SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO DIGITAL LITERACY
TASK FORCE. AND BACK IN TWENTY
ELEVEN I SERVED AS FAR AS ON A
NASA TASK FORCE BASED OUT OF
GODDARD SPACE FLIGHT CENTER. IN
MARYLAND ON INCORPORATING
GEOSPATIAL TECHNOLOGY IN THE K.
TWELVE CLASSROOMS. IN THE CITY
ONE OF THINGS I HAVE NOTICED
SINCE THE TWENTY ELEVEN
EXPERIENCES I HAVE SEEN AS FAR
AS PROGRESS MADE. IN OTHER
STATES VERSUS CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S ONE UNDERLYING ISSUE AS
FAR AS ON A LOT OF DISCUSSION
HERE THAT HAS NOT BEEN RAISED.
IS THAT I HAVE NOTICED THAT
THOSE STATES THAT ARE MAKING
PROGRESS ARE STATES THAT HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S THAT
ARE VERY PROACTIVE DEALING WITH
DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY. AND
CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IT'S EXTREMELY
PASSIVE I MEAN THE AD IN TILL
WE WORK ON CHANGING THE
CULTURE. AND THE POLICIES IN
OUR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE ARE GOING TO GET
NO WHERE THE DEPARTMENT THEIR
CULTURE IS WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
UNLESS IT'S IN A FRAMEWORK OR A
STANDARD. AND WE KNOW HOW
FREQUENTLY THAT DOES GET
UPDATED IN CHANGES CHANGES IN
THE OTHER THING AS FAR AS
KEEPING UP OR PROMOTING
ANYTHING AS FAR AS ON EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES WE LEAVE IT UP TO
THE PUBLISHERS AND THE
DEVELOPERS. AND SCHOOLS REACT
TO THE PUBLISHERS AND
DEVELOPERS AS SALES PERSONS.
AND WITH THE BRAT WITH WITH THE
INCREASING RAPIDITY OF
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN OUR CULTURE AND OUR K.
TWELVE SYSTEM. ISN'T PROVIDING
WHAT IS NEEDED FOR OUR K.
TWELVE STUDENTS TO SUCCEED IN
FACT LET RECENTLY WITHIN THE
LAST YEAR I'VE STARTED PICKING
UP THAT WE'RE NOW. JUST A STRAY.
I OUT. IN LETTERS. LETTER GAS.
TO A WORKFORCE COMPETITIVENESS
GAP AND I MEAN JUST HERE WITH
THIS HEARING ITS TITLE IN ITS
EMPHASIS AS FAR AS COMPUTER
SCIENCE. MINCED OF HOW BALLING
HOT MORE AT YOUR TO WE'RE
DEALING WITH IT IN A WOMEN I
FOR OVER. BROUGH NOW MULTI
TOUCH IT IS IT'S A- IT TECH
IT'S DID YOU LITERACY IT'S
JACK'S LOOK DOT COMPUTERS. NEED
TO BROAD THAT'S BEANS SELL SELL
OUR STUDENTS THE AND- I'M IF
THEY DON'T BECOME. OF LACK
COMPETITOR IN THE- EIGHT AND
FIVE NOW IS FAR AS ON THE ISSUE
I ALSO A THE CLASS PROVIDING
LOG DO AND ONE SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE GRAY SURPRISE AND IS
RATHER HELLO WHICH IS CáC IN.
THIS HI MINORITY HI IMMIGRANT
SECOND LANGUAGE AND THIS PAST
YEAR FROM THE- WEB MAPPING MANY
COURSE OF WHAT WE DO WE FEEL
THE TEAM AND CALIFORNIA'S
STORYMAP COMPETITION AND LAST
SPRING THEY SWEPT THE
COMPETITION DEFEATING THEM
AFFLUENCE ARE THE MORE AFFLUENT
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN NOT
BELIES THAT COMPETITION FOR
YEARS- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. I'M ISABEL GARCIA I'M
A CTA LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE BUT
I'M I WANT TO THANK THE
DISTINGUISHED PANELS AND ALSO-
MANAGER FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING I'M I'M
ACTUALLY GONNA TELL YOU
SOMETHING THAT WORKS I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF HAVING ONE
DAUGHTER. AND SHE'S TWENTY
SEVEN NOW BUT I WOULD KEPT
PUSHING THE SCIENCES MATH AND
SCIENCES AND I WANT TO TELL
YOU- WHAT WORKED THAT I THINK
IS. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT IN AND
OUT SCHOOL- ON IT THAT WORKED
AT BUT I THINK IT'S NOT AS WELL
KNOWN SO ONE OF THEM IS THE CSU
CAMPUS. HERE IN SACRAMENTO AT
TALENTS. AND THEY HAVE HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHERS WHO OFFER
COURSES FOR STUDENTS IN GRADES
SIX THROUGH NINE AND THE RISK
SHE WAS INTERESTED IN COMPUTER
GRAPHICS I MEAN FOLLOWING AT
THE INTEREST- THEY HAD CODING
EVERYTHING YOU COULD EVEN GET
HIGH CREDIT. AND I KNOW HOW
MANY THE C. OFFER AT THE
CHALLENGERS THINK THE NEWS OF.
FOR ALL ASPECTS OF EVERY KEY.
WE EVER BEING OFF. ARM OFF. I
THINK SHOULD BE YOU OWN WIDELY
PROMOTED THE OTHER THING THAT-
I LIVE HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I HAD TO SEND MY
DAUGHTER JUST SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO GO TO A CAMP OF
FEMALE SCIENTISTS FOR A WEEK.
FROM THE SCIENCE OF MAKE UP TO
MARINE BIOLOGY SO I THINK
PROMOTING MORE. IT'S NOT SHE
TOOK THE SOCCER CAMPS SO IT'S
F. LENNIX OF COURSE BUT WHY NOT
ALSO HAVE THE MUSIC AND ALSO OF
THE SCIENCE- AND THEN THE
OTHER- I JUST BOUGHT A BOOK FOR
A BABY SHOWER. IT'S CALLED
EXTRA FOR ITS WERE BABIES SO
WHEN YOU SAY HELLO HOW YOUNG
CAN WE START. YEAR OLD YES.
THAT YOUNG. AND THEN YOU TO
ABOUT THE GAMING MY IT MIGHT MY
DAUGHTER WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. SO SHE GREW UP WITH
MACHINES AND THE GAME BOYS AND
THE VIDEO GAMES AND SHE REALLY
WANTED TO GO TO UC RIVER. SIDE
AND GET A DEGREE IN GAMING BUT
OF COURSE THERE WERE MANY
OBSTACLES THERE AND ONE OF THE
OBSTACLES YOU ENCOUNTER WAS THE
ALGORITHMS AND SHOULD NEVER
REALLY. BEEN INTRODUCED THAT IN
CASE FOR TWELVE SYSTEM SO I
THINK IT WAS UNTIL SHE GOT TO
COLLEGE SO I THINK THAT AGAIN.
YEAH ALL OF THESE IT TAKING
THEIR INTERESTS AND- I YOU KNOW
I REMEMBER THE COMICON
CONVENTIONS THAT SHE USED TO GO
TO WHY DON'T WE HAVE BRUCE AIR
ABOUT. YOU KNOW GIRLS IN CODING
OR WHATEVER I MEAN P. S. A.'S
IN YOUR COMMUNITIES THERE'S A
LOT WE COULD DO. THAT THAT SOME
OF THE PTA- YOU KNOW. THEY
COULD BE. PROMOTING MORE OF.
THE UNDER UTILIZED MUSEUMS AND
ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES IN EACH
COMMUNITY IF YOU HAVE IT ON
SCIENCE. WHATEVER SO ANYWAY
THOSE ARE COMMENTS HIS
APPEARANCE THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS JESSICA SOCCER I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK A
PROJECT OF CHILDREN NOW I'D
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS AND HER STAFF FOR
CONVENING THIS. IMPORTANT
HEARING- WHERE WE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THE NEED FOR A CONTINUED
IN ROBUST INVESTMENT IN STEM
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE NOT ONLY
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT. WHAT
RESOURCES MIGHT BE NEEDED FOR
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION BUT ALSO
THE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING OF
OUR TEACHER WORK FORCE T. K. TO
TWELVE. AS WELL AS AND THIS IS
INVESTMENT KEEP. IDEALLY WOULD
BE SUSTAINED AND ROBUST AND NOT
IN ONE TIME FUNDING AS THIS IS
AN EDUCATIONAL SHIFT AND
MOVEMENT THAT WILL REQUIRE MANY
YEARS TO IMPLEMENT. IN ADDITION
WE ALSO LIKE TO SEE INVEST IN
OUR STEM TEACHER WORK FORCE
THAT REALLY TARGETS THE
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES. OF A STEM
TEACHER RICK. HIGH QUALITY STEM
TEACHERS THEIR UNIQUE
CHALLENGES SPECIFIC TO STEM
TEACHERS THAT REALLY NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL AS
DIVERSIFYING OUR TEACHER WORK
FORCE THANK YOU. Q. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE- THAT JOINED US
HERE TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC- IN THE HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANKS.